So, jetzt fängt's an, wieder mal.
Hallo.
Hallo. Hier ist der Tim.
Hallo, hier ist Darth Vader.
Hier ist Darth Vader. Und?
Mein Name hab ich vergessen.
Luke Skywalker.
Ich bin dein Vater.
Und wir sitzen hier alle. It's impossible! Wir sitzen im Raumschiff und Max macht gleich kräftig Anwendungen hier von der neuen Technik.
Die ich übrigens nicht mag, ich kling damit vollverschnupft.
Du klingst auch ohne die Technik, total verschnupft, weil du hier die ganze Zeit schnüffelst und dich abhängig machst von Nasenspray, wo andere Leute aus der Apotheke wieder rausgeschickt werden. Nein, sie kriegen jetzt nichts mehr. Herr Winde, sie hatten schon genug.
Ich bin schon auf der Black-Office.
Nein, sie müssen es mir geben, sie müssen es mir geben.
Die nationale No-Nasentropfen-Nasenspray-Liste, die verwaltet wird von allen Apotheken.
Na wie auch immer. Auf jeden Fall, der Herbst kündigt sich an und die Nasen sind in zunehmendem Maße verschnupft, noch nicht ausreichend verschnupft, um dich dann doch noch für einen kleinen Podcast herzuhalten. Welcher da ist? Moba Max Nummer 17.
Boah, siebzehn schon.
Ja, der jetzt zu diesem Zeitpunkt noch keinen Namen hat, weil dieser Name, wie immer, entsteht einfach erst, während Darth Vader ihn eratmet. Siebzehn und vier.
Woher kommt die vier?
Ja, ja, wir finden schon was. Und wir sind heute auch mal wieder live und wir winken mal kurz in den Chat. Und jetzt hoffen wir natürlich, dass der Chat auch zurückwinkt. Drei, zwei, eins. Man muss ja auch den Delay ein bisschen einrechnen.
Ah, da kann das Wink, aber wirklich bei eins.
Funktioniert. Sofa Kartoffel winkt, Basti winkt. Super. Hier wird ordentlich gewinkt. Das motiviert.
Die denken jetzt alles live.
Ja, dann wollen wir mal, oder? Nachdem wir letztes Mal so viel über Geld geredet haben, reden wir heute mal über Inhalte. Eine Themenkarte. Ja, du hast ja schon angedeutet, wir waren unterwegs. Mobile Max war mal wieder mobil, wenn gleich Max auch nicht. Genau, für euch unterwegs. Und wir haben uns ja zu diesem iPhone Tech Talk angemeldet. Vor einigen Monaten schon, oder? Vor zwei Monaten. Und kurz vorher kriegt man dann auch eine Bestätigung, und zwar nicht nur eine Bestätigung, dass man sich angemeldet hat, sondern auch, dass man kommen darf.
Oh, so drei Mails hab ich bekommen. Einmal, dass ich mich angemeldet hab, einmal die Bestätigung und einmal noch einen Tag vor die Erinnerungs-Mail, dass ich auch wirklich hingehen soll. Wenn ich das gar nicht vergesse.
Du hast eine Mail bekommen, wo explizit drin stand, dass du jetzt auch kommen darfst?
Ja, mitten drin noch mal.
Hab ich das auch bekommen?
Ja, bestimmt. Und dann am Sonntag noch einmal die Erinnerungs-Mail. Ja, richtig, du hast recht.
Drei Stück. Genau. Und dann waren wir da. Ich hatte mal angefangen zu zählen, aber ich hab's dann nicht ganz zu Ende gebracht, weil dann grad die Pause anfing. Aber da waren viele Leute, oder? Das war nicht leer.
Also es war ein ganz schön großer Raum. Henry Fordbau und der FU. Dahle in Berlin.
Also tausend waren es nicht, aber es waren einige hundert.
Dreihundert? Vierhundert?
Mindestens.
So ein richtiger schöner großer Vorlesungssaal voll mit?
Genau. Henry Fordbau, das ist so ein großer Vorlesungssaal mit...
Bin ich so....
Mal gucken, wie viele Plätze da sind. Nicht das erste Mal, dass Apple dort Veranstaltungen macht. Ich war da schon mal. Und irgendwie haben die da wohl ein ganz gutes Verhältnis. Zumindest ein ausreichend gutes Verhältnis, dass Apple dort irgendwie auftreten dann. Da müssen sie wahrscheinlich auch ein bisschen für Geld bezahlen. Wär auch ganz angemessen. Auf jeden Fall haben sie da ganz ordentlich aufgefahren. Es gab Essen. War jetzt nicht so Essen im Sinne von, dass man da jetzt fett sich irgendwie... Häbschen halt.... die Lammkeulen rausziehen konnte da.
Ihr wart ja auch nicht zum Essen da.
Nee, wir waren nicht zum Essen da. Es gab halt so Häbschen und es gab so gefüllte Croissants und es gab irgendwie Kaffee. Und es gab vor allem eine Menge Pausen, was auch ganz gut war. Dann gab es immer so dreiviertel Stunde Talks. Fing gleich mit zwei hintereinander an. Das erste war erstmal so allgemeine Begrüßung plus, naja, so Daten, die wir alle nur zu gut kennen, also Verbreitung des iPhones und so weiter. So ein paar Marktzahlen, was im App Store so abgeht und pippa-pum. Und dann in zunehmendem Maße, Schritt für Schritt, Vorträge über, wie man denn entwickelt für das iPhone. Das war schon wirklich explizit aufs iPhone und explizit auf Development gemacht. In der Mitte des Tages haben sie es dann nochmal gesplittet für die einen, die halt am SDK Interesse hatten. Das war so der Großteil, wenn ich das richtig sehe. Und dann gab es wohl nochmal ein kleineres Session, parallel, da war ich aber nicht, wo dieses IT-Deployment ein Thema war, das wir auch schon mal hatten, iPhone-Konfigurator und so weiter. Also wie konfigurier ich Telefone und mach das halt in einer großen Firma oder Universitäten, deploy dann irgendwelche Setups. Hab's wie gesagt nicht gesehen, aber das war das, was auch angekündigt war, worum es ging. Und Web-Entwicklung war das andere Thema. Also da ging es sozusagen mehr um dieses, wie programmiere ich dafür von der Server-Seite her. Und das andere war halt, wie programmiere ich wirklich auf dem Gerät, SDK. Da sind wir dann irgendwie auch geblieben. Ich war ein bisschen groggy an dem Tag. Gegen späten Nachmittag bin ich dann noch mal eine halbe Stunde eingeschlafen. Das lag daran, dass dieser Italiener dann mir so ein bisschen zu monoton, würde ich nicht sagen, aber es war so ein bisschen, da war ein bisschen zu wenig Schwung drin. Also Italiener, die dann eigentlich sprechen, kann schwierig sein. Der war eigentlich gut, aber mir fehlte so ein bisschen die Verbe, die dann die anderen Sprecher vorher schon einen Tag gelegt haben. Dieser Britte, den fand ich zum Beispiel richtig klasse am Anfang.
Und sind die direkt aus Cappuccino eingeflogen? Oder sind das...
Das waren alles...
Welche Schulen Leute?
Das waren Europäer. Der dritte Italiener.
Ein Spanier. Am Ende war ein Spanier, oder?
Ich weiß nicht mehr ganz genau.
Aber der war schlecht. Also den konntest du ja kaum verstehen.
Ganz am Ende im Sinne von als es um Optimieren ging und so.
Der hat zu schnell gesprochen und zu... Also so im spanischen Speed...
Das war ein Italiener.
Speed-Englisch, bist du sicher? Na von mir aus. Aber das war zu schnell. Zu schnell und der war zu schlecht.
Ja.
Nicht vom Inhalt her, sondern vom Aufruf.
Vom Inhalt war es okay. Vom Inhalt war es wirklich gut. Es wurde halt sehr viel über STK geredet und vor allem, was mich beeindruckt hat, war, dass sie erst mal angefangen haben mit wie gestaltet man eine Applikation. Also, bevor irgendwas über, wie man seinen Xcode... Also, sie haben ganz am Anfang die Tools vorgestellt. Aber nur so, hier ist Xcode, leider, dass man erst mal wusste, wo man war. Und dann gingen sie halt hin und meinten, 50% bis 80% eurer Tätigkeit sollte das Design ausmachen. Und der Rest ist irgendwie Coding. Coden müsste nicht so viel. Ihr müsst euch Gedanken über das Design der Applikationen machen. Und haben dann eine ganze Reihe von Beispielen gegeben, wo das Design gut war. Also haben viele Programme aus dem App Store vorgestellt und darauf hingewiesen, was sie daran jetzt besonders gut finden und wo die jetzt im Einzelnen gute Arbeit geleistet haben. Also mir war eigentlich fast alles bekannt, außer dieser einen Applikation, die sich gelbt, was es nur im amerikanischen Store gibt, offensichtlich. Also ich fand's gut. Es war dann für die DieHards, also für die Leute, die es schon entwickelt haben, es war ja einige da, für die war natürlich jetzt nicht so viel zu holen, eher so gegen Ende, als es dann so um die Optimierung ging. Es hing natürlich auch sehr davon ab, wie viel man selber hier schon gemacht hat. Ich meine, du bist ja Entwickler. Hast du da irgendwas rausziehen können?
Also es ist ja alles sehr, sehr oberflächlich gewesen. Also das ist eigentlich, würde ich fast behaupten, für Leute, die erst loslegen wollen. Auch die, die ganz gerade erst schon angefangen haben. Das ist gleich das, was du als erstes lernst, was sie da erzählen. Es ist nur noch mal als Bestätigung, es ist noch mal gut, dass man weiß, okay, man hat alles richtig gelernt. Weil sonst hättest du da etwas anderes gelernt, aber das war nicht der Fall. Es war alles, was du so in den Examples auch siehst und liest. Was ein bisschen gut ist vielleicht, aber das habe ich halt auch schon selber rausgefunden. Die Apple Examples, die sind alle speicherverschwendend. Also die sind alle nicht opaque, sondern transparent. Das soll man aus Speedgründen nicht machen. Und die halten ihre Views, alle feste Review-Controller. Das soll man auch nicht machen. Und die Apple Examples sind aber so, das merkst du aber nach einer Weile ganz schnell selber beim Programmieren. Aber auch die ganzen Optimierer und ihr müsst Speicher sparen, Tipps. Sie haben es nochmal so oft wiederholt, dass das jetzt wirklich jeder weiß und dass man auch selber weiß, ok, du musst dir halt um Speicher kümmern.
Das stimmt, da haben die richtig drauf eingehämmert.
Hab ich mich schon auch immer drum gekümmert, aber ich weiß, dass das richtig war und dass ich es auch weiter ganz doll tun muss. Aber ansonsten...
Ja, ich fand das ganz gut, dass Sie diese kritischen Sachen mehrfach betont haben, insbesondere Memory-Management. Und auch so, Sie haben zum Beispiel so klare Vergleiche gemacht. Das iPhone ist kein Desktop-Computer. Das iPhone ist kein Desktop-Computer. Da sind Tabelle aufgestellt, wo so alle technischen Daten vom Mac und alle technischen Daten vom iPhone aufgezeigt wurden. Die Kiste ist langsam und so weiter. Sie hat kein Second-Level-Cache und Pippa-Po. Klar, das iPhone ist nicht langsam im eigentlichen Sinne für ein Telefon. Es ist ein fixer Bursch, gerade was da so eine Beschleunigung mit drin ist. Aber es muss da eben anders drauf programmiert. Und es sind auch noch so Sachen wie, dass der Simulator auf dem Mac eben kein Emulator ist.
Das wäre ein guter Tipp gewesen vor zwei, drei Monaten. Also, dann programmierst du gegen eine API und stellst dann später fest, die gibt es auf dem iPhone gar nicht.
Ach, wieso? Da ist auch noch eine API drin, die es nicht gibt?
Na, der greift auf die echte Mac OS-API zurück. Auf der Mac OS-API gibt es halt Core Services und auf dem iPhone gibt es nur ein Subset oder was auch immer.
Nein, ich meine jetzt den Simulator, den iPhone-Simulator. Wenn du dein Programm, dein iPhone-Programm auf dem Mac in diesem Simulator laufen lässt, dann läuft es halt als Intel-Binary.
Ja, aber auch gegen die Mac OS-API.
Und der Simulator ist nur das GUI des iPhones, aber unten drunter hast du alles, was du auf dem Mac hast. Ach so, das iPhone hat aber nicht alles. Und dann kannst du gegen was linken, ohne sich da irgendwas beschwert. Und dann testest du es auf dem iPhone und dann sagt er dir, ist nicht. Muss man ein bisschen aufpassen.
Also ich find ja diesen Simulator, wenn ich mit dem mal so ein bisschen rumspiele, also was mir auffällt, wenn dann Mobile Safari im Simulator abstürzt, dann krieg ich die ganz normale macOS-Fehlermeldung, hey dein Programm ist abgestürzt, willst du das vielleicht an Apple melden?
Ja, weil halt das Webkit des Macs abgestürzt ist.
Ach, dann ist wirklich das Webkit des Macs auch abgestürzt? Oder das Mobile Safari. Und wenn ich ein Programm schreibe, was aus Netz zugreift, dann fragt Lillis Nisch auch tapfer nach. Und zwar nicht, dass der Simulator drauf zugreifen will, sondern wie dein Programm heißt, möchte gern drauf zugreifen. Also das scheinen auch echte native Intel-Prozesse zu sein, die da laufen, oder? Sieht man die?
Das haben sie ja auch gesagt. Ich weiß nicht, ob nun das PS aussieht, hab ich noch nicht ausprobiert. Kann ich mir gut vorstellen, wenn Lillis Nisch schon sieht, dass dieser Prozess als solcher... Klar, muss eigentlich ein eigener Prozess sein. Das war schon auch am einfachsten. Wie auch immer. Also so eine Sache haben sie dort erklärt. Also so für Einsteiger. Und darum ging es. Die allermeisten Leute, die da waren, waren auch... Am Anfang haben sie so ein bisschen gefragt, wer so schon mal Software entwickelt hat. Und ich würde sagen...
Da war ich ja leider noch nicht da, weil ich kam ein bisschen zu spät.
Ja, die große Mehrheit war sozusagen Einsteiger. Es waren einige da, die schon entwickeln und auch einige da, die Programme im App Store haben. Aber die waren übersichtlich gestreut. Und die große Mehrheit kam dahin, um sich einen Plan zu machen. Ich denke, für die war es auch gemacht. Nee, ich hab einen Freund von mir getroffen, der beim großen deutschen Verlag, wo Zeitungen hergestellt werden, mit großen Buchstaben arbeitet.
Kenn ich den auch? War der auch da?
Weiß ich jetzt nicht. Wie auch immer, auf jeden Fall haben die da einen Tag freigegeben. Und es ist jedem freigestellt gewesen, da hinzukommen und sind dann aber auch da alle gelatscht gekommen. Da liefen dann gleich so ein Trupp von 5-6 Leuten da rum und haben sich das halt gegeben. Das iPhone hat gerade eine Aufmerksamkeit in der Entwicklerwelt, die ist...
Schon fast so hoch.
Wie sagt man so schön? Unparalleled. Ja, so war das da. Max, hast du noch Fragen? Ich weiß nicht, was ich dazu noch sagen soll. Wir haben den Flash getroffen, unter anderem. Einige Hörer sind uns entgegengekommen.
Wir haben nicht den Flash getroffen.
Der Flash. Der Flash ist jetzt hier auch gerade im Chat und hört, wie wir das sagen. Und wir werden auch gerade darauf hingewiesen, dass unser Panning zu extrem ist. Da werde ich gleich mal ein bisschen drin drehen. Das ist unsere Links-Rechts-Verteilung.
Ich glaube, wenn wir Tim nicht bald zu seinem neuen Mixer fragen, dann explodiert er vor lauter Spannung. Das auch.
Aber jetzt sagen wir erstmal, wie wir dann auch alles getroffen haben. Der Flash ist unter anderem auch derjenige, der diese hübsche IRC-Applikation fürs iPhone gehackt hat, die Roms-Applikation. Die hatten wir hier schon mal besprochen. Haben wir dann auch gleich wieder ein bisschen gelobt und Verbesserungsvorschläge ausgetauscht. Und dann gab es noch so ein, zwei andere. Unter anderem den Philipp, der da stand, der dann auf einmal verschwunden ist, bevor ich richtig anfangen konnte, mit ihm zu sprechen. Wir grüßen auf jeden Fall Philipp. Und dann waren noch ein paar andere da, die mir jetzt gerade so vom Namen nicht einfallen. Aber wir sagen irgendwie Hallo und schön, dass ihr uns hört.
Man hat auf jeden Fall einige Bekannte auch getroffen, auch schon aus früheren Zeiten, ehemaligen Firmen usw.
Auf jeden Fall, war echt eine Menge los. Großes breites Interesse.
Und auch Leute, die man nicht kannte, aber die man halt vom Sehen von diesen Veranstaltungen immer wieder sieht. Das sind ja auch immer die gleichen und die ganzen Kongressbesucher und so.
Ah, der Philipp ist auch gerade im Chat und er meinte, er musste los. Na gut. Ja, ich würde sagen, das war's. Also ich fand die Veranstaltung ganz gut. Die allerletzte habe ich mir nicht mehr gegeben. Die Sache mit dem, da musste ich dann weg. Am Schluss ging es halt nur noch darum, wie ich meine Applikationen in den App Store. Ich würde sagen, für eine Entwicklereinführung war das schon relativ detailliert, weil sie haben einfach eine ganze Menge Beispiele genannt. Auch diese konkreten Probleme mit Code-Beispiel. Also da waren zumindest mal so 10, 20, 20 nicht, aber 10 Zahlen Code schon mal auch immer noch dazu konkret angegeben, um eben zu zeigen, wie man irgendetwas invoked, wie man irgendwas vermeidet.
Habt ihr gesehen, dass wir ja noch mal kurz zeigen, hier so Objective-See, wie das geht und...
Richtig genau, Objective-See haben wir ja noch mal erklärt.
Objekte alloziert und freigibt, was man dazu beachten hat und so und was man nicht machen soll. Ich kann mich da auch noch nicht so mit anfreunden. Ich hab's mal probiert, aber irgendwie ist ja alles so langsam und schräg und komisch und so.
Langsam?
Ich hab hier gerade so ein Minitool, das lädt von... Von Pirate Bay so eineinhalb Millionen Torrens mit lauter Zeug runter und macht und tut. Und wenn ich das halt per Garbage-Collection mache, dann reichen meine zwei Gigabyte nicht, dass dieses Programm läuft. Und wenn ich jetzt alles von Hand hab, hab ich mal optimiert von Release. Ich war erst bei 1,2 Gigabyte. Das ist ein altes Objekt. Das hat halt viel Strings und Zeug und eigentlich ist das gar nicht geeignet für so... Aber nee. Objekt ist sie an sich. Man sollte es eigentlich ein bisschen mehr C-mäßig machen. Aber ich hab alles mal mit Endestrings gemacht. Und dann bin ich von 1,2 Gigabyte bis auf 600 MB runtergekommen, indem ich mal ordentlich release und nicht so Auto-Release nehme, sondern gleich sofort und nicht erst warte, bis der Loop zu Ende ist, weil das ist halt eben schlecht. Aber mit Garbage Collection dachte ich, schaltest mal einen und dann ist alles super. Aber nee, es ging gar nicht mehr und musste ich lassen. Ging nicht.
Ja, aber jetzt hast du auch offensichtlich einen extrem speziellen Fall genommen.
Das kann sein. Klar, für irgendwelche Easy-Peasy-Tools kannst du es natürlich einschalten, aber bei den Easy-Peasy-Tools ist es sowieso egal, ob du mit Speicher herum verschwendest oder nicht. Also da ist es ja dann...
Nee, wieso? Wenn die Programme hinreichend lange laufen, ist doch schön, wenn die nicht langsam volltropfen.
Also Garbage Collection kann gut funktionieren. Ich weiß nicht, wie gut Apple mittlerweile ihre Garbage Collection hinbekommen hat, aber man muss schon in zeitkritischen oder speicherkritischen Sachen, ist es natürlich schwierig. Hier gibt es übrigens gerade noch kurz den Hinweis im Chat, dass die Apple-Jungs am Ende des iPhone-Tech-Talks gesagt haben sollen, dass es neben dem Beginner's Day auch noch technischer, also dass sie bald wiederkommen wollen und es neben dem Beginner's Day, der das wohl war, auch technischer werden wollen. Das ist doch schonmal was. Ja, ach so, wir sollen mal erklären, was Garbage Collection ist. Weiß ich nicht, aber...
Kannst du mich auf eine ältere Sendung verweisen?
Weiß ich jetzt nicht. Zumindest auf keinen Chaos Radio Express zu dem Thema.
Vier Stunden zum Thema Garbage Collection.
Ja, das gibt eine Menge her. Ich sag dir, das mach ich auch noch. Also Garbage Collection heißt einfach nur, dass sich die Programmiersprache selber darum kümmert, nicht mehr gebrauchten Speicher und Variablen, die halt auf was verweisen, freizugeben. Das ist sozusagen, da kommt der Müllmann und sammelt die halt einfach ein.
Was normalerweise dafür sorgt, dass man, normalerweise muss man das selber machen.
Aber den Müllmann muss man halt bezahlen, wenn man das nicht selber macht. Und das ist so ein eventuelles Problem. Aber manchmal kann man sich das halt leisten, wenn man faul ist.
Könnte man ein bisschen so sagen. Also wenn man irgendwo vergisst, Speicher freizugeben, wenn man Speicher reserviert und dann vergisst, ihn wieder freizugeben und dann nochmal Speicher reserviert und dann wieder vergisst, freizugeben, wenn man das in einer Funktion vergessen hat, dann ist irgendwann mal der Speicher voll. Und da kann so eine Garbage Collection unter Umständen ziemlich hilfreich sein.
Auf jeden Fall. Leaking war ja auch in diesem Tech Talk einer der größten Themen, weil ganz klar jedes Programm, das läuft und Speicher holt und holt und holt und holt und nicht wieder freigibt, da wächst natürlich dann der Speicherbedarf. Das kann dann unter Umständen nochmal ganz schnell gehen. Das ist immer bekloppt. Und das ist ja exakt genau das, was eine Garbage Collection auch verhindern soll. Plus, Garbage Collection ist nicht trivial. Also es ist so, man denkt ja so ganz einfach drüber nach, naja, wieso?
Sobald es schlecht wird, schmeiß ich es weg.
Es ist nicht so einfach, weil es gibt ja Cross-Referencing und das muss eine Garbage Collection auflösen können und dann wird es ein bisschen komplizierter.
Genau, also wenn du zum Beispiel eine zirkuläre Liste hast, so A zeigt auf B, B zeigt auf C, C zeigt auf D.
Das hatten wir aber tatsächlich schon mal hier.
D zeigt wieder auf A, dann kann die Garbage Collection die billigeren das erstmal nicht auflösen, die modernen, aber die können das alles.
Genau, und dann ist da immer auch eine Frage der Strategie. Wann macht man das? Checkt man häufig den Speicher? Oder kann man das schon vorher taggen? Es gibt eine ganze Menge Entwicklungen in dem Bereich, extrem spannend. Und es gibt auch viele Ansätze für Real-Time Garbage Collection, die auch diesen Real-Time-Anforderungen entsprechen. Und ja, ich kenn jetzt den Garbage-Collector, den Apple in Objective-C 2.0 eingebaut hat, nicht so gut.
Der ist aber gestern gerade als Open Source veröffentlicht worden. Kannst du nachlesen alles. Wo der veröffentlicht worden ist? Ja, ich glaube gestern. Ich weiß nicht, wie der heißt.
Hab ich aber nicht vorhin gelesen.
Ich schon.
Nochmal los, du hast ja deine Quelle notiert.
Ja, mein Google-Reader.
Google-History.
Nun ja, also ich denke, diesen iPhone-Tech-Talk-Kram können wir zumachen. Es heißt, sie werden wiederkommen, das finde ich gut. Das finde ich auch gut. Ich fand das Angebot, vielleicht das nochmal abschneiden. Ich fand das Angebot fand ich okay. Sie beherbergen da 300, 400 Leute. Die kriegen alle fressen, die kriegen alle Kaffee.
Weiß ich, wie viele Leute durch die Gegend für teuer Geld?
Genau, fünf Leute waren da unterwegs. Und dann noch ein paar, die Mädels, die da vorne am Stand standen. Also da waren schon so acht Personen vielleicht im Hintergrundkram, vielleicht so zehn Personen damit beschäftigt. Und die fliegen ja...
Am nächsten Tag waren die gleich wieder in Madrid.
Genau, die haben so richtig Hardcore.
Der Tor geht bis 17.30 Uhr. Der Flieger geht nicht vor sieben Uhr, wir müssen ja auch einpacken, machen, tun. Und dann kommen die da, weiß ich nicht, sind die spätestens um neun in Madrid im Hotel. Oder frühestens, sagen wir, frühestens. Und morgens geht's gleich wieder weiter.
Genau, und man muss das ja auch noch aufbauen und abbauen.
Das kann ja ein anderer machen, zur Not. Vielleicht haben die einen ja immer vor, fliegt und nachfliegt und so weiter.
Das ist vorstellbar.
Denke schon. Die kommen dann aber auch noch dazu. Also es kostet Apple ne Menge Geld.
Das denke ich auch.
Aber was macht man nicht alles so für 30%?
Ja, 30% was?
Von dem, was die Leute an Programmen schreiben und verdienen.
Ach so, ja, die 30%. Naja, und auch die ganzen Prozente, die sie dabei einstreichen, weil sich Leute halt die Telefone kaufen, damit sie diese Programme benutzen können. Mittlerweile hab ich auf meinem iPhone schon Programme, wo ich sagen würde, das ist so das, was ich auf meinem Telefon haben will. Ich kaufe mir kein Telefon ohne sowas.
Und was hat dich das gekostet jetzt, softwaremäßig?
Hab ich noch nicht ausgerechnet.
Geht auch gar nicht, oder? Apple ist ja nicht blöd. Doch, geht das?
Na klar, ich kriege ja immer die Rechnungen zugeschickt.
Ja, Einzelheit, muss alle zusammenadieren.
Naja, einzeln im Sinne von immer, was man so in einer Woche zusammen oder innerhalb eines Tages, ich weiß nicht ganz genau, das wird irgendwie kumuliert.
Bisschen zusammengefasst, schon alle paar Tage.
Da gab es ja irgendwann mal einen langen... Autozone heißt übrigens der Garbage Collector für ein...
Auto was?
Autozone.
Autozone heißt der Garbage Collector von Objective-C 2.0.
Und ist now available.
Quelle?
Packen wir kurz in den Chat rein.
Genau, mach doch mal.
Dann haben wir alle.
Wo denn?
Autozone Nashville is talking. Ich glaub ich bin falsch.
Wo bist du denn?
Aha, auf opensourceevel.com. Ach so, ist jetzt direkt der TRI oder was? Gibt's da nicht auch noch ein Announcement für?
Ja, warte mal, ich suche mal... Announcement hab ich nicht.
Da hab ich aber echt gar nichts von gelesen. Ist mir mal wieder total runtergegangen.
Du musst ja tolle Quellen haben.
Mal sehen, während wir uns da mit den Apple-Jungs rumschlagen, dann ist Max hier voll undercover unterwegs.
Ich hier die echten Quellen.
Ich meine, das möchte man ja auch erwarten, dass so was veröffentlicht wird. Autozon. Okay, müsste man sich mal angucken. Hoffentlich gibt's auch Dokumentationen dazu.
Der wird wohl auch in McRuby eingesetzt.
Sprich weiter. Woher weißt du denn sowas?
Ich hab doch grad den Link gepostet.
Ja, den Link, aber wo hast du den Link her? Ran-Caro? Ran-Caro. Das ist meine Quelle.
Wir haben übrigens schon mal im elften Mobile Max Podcast darüber unterhalten, dass es auf dem iPhone keine Garbage Collection gibt.
Fairly Generic Scanning Conservative Generational Multithreaded Language Agnostic Collector. Aha. Ja, das ist doch das, was ich wissen wollte. Nein, ich kann euch das noch nicht übersetzen. Da gibt's so verschiedene lustige Adjektive bei Garbage Kollektoren, die man, ja, die man zu interpretieren verstehen muss. Also ich notiere mir jetzt mal Garbage Collection als Chaos Radio Express-Thema.
Jetzt reicht's, jetzt wird's zurückgeschlagen. Dann kann ich ja ein bisschen Ding-Ding-Werbung machen, weil ich will auch mal was announcen, und zwar die nächste Chaos Radio Sendung im richtigen Radio, bis Ende November. Datum ist jetzt mal selber aus, ich glaube, 26. Und das wird um das Thema Bitterwind gehen.
Wie das war nicht im Radio?
Das meine ich so, das weiß ich schon.
Du meinst, das war nicht auf UKW?
So hieß es.
Ja und?
Wollte ich jetzt mal gesagt haben.
Okay, und soll das wieder so sein wie unsere Sendung oder?
Ja, ich denke schon.
Ja? Nochmal Technik? Oder was anders nennen?
Über BitTorrent. Was da genau kommt, weiß ich noch nicht so, aber da ist schon noch Erklärungsbedarf bei den Leuten.
Gut, umso besser.
Das ist ja eine ganz andere Hörerschaft da im Radio da draußen. Die sind ja nicht so Nerds, sondern sind ja mehr so normale und da kann man glaube ich schon nochmal ein bisschen erklären, wie BitTorrent funktioniert. Auch muss man noch ein bisschen anders erklären, glaube ich.
So, jetzt machen wir den Tech Talk das Thema aber zu und können fortschreiten.
Dann einmal die nächste Karte bitte.
Was wolltest du mich fragen, Max?
Was ich dich fragen wollte? Gute Frage. Was wollte ich fragen?
Keine Ahnung.
Ich weiß es tatsächlich nicht mehr. Ich habe am Wochenende mal ein iPhone verloren und es ist wieder aufgetaucht.
Du hast es angerufen und dann lagst du unterm Sofa.
Genau. Ich war unterwegs, habe es im Club verloren. Ich dachte, das wäre ein für alle Mal weg. Offensichtlich sind ein paar Leute darauf umgetrampelt, weil es jetzt an der Seite so ein bisschen aufgebogen ist. Aber die haben mich dann empfangen, als es doch zwei Stunden wieder da war und ich schon in der Zeit ganz traurig abgezottelt, trottelt bin. Wie heißt denn der? Ist das eigentlich Stella? Irgendwo in der Friedrichstraße. Sieht so aus wie so ein halber Hausbesetzes-Ding. Ich hatte nicht damit gerechnet, das Telefon jemals wiederzumachen. Das war schon ein ganz normaler Lack und Leder Club. Ja, ist wieder aufgetaucht, mein iPhone ist wieder da.
Hat man es dir wiedergegeben oder hast du es irgendwo gefunden?
Es hat einen Barkeeper gefunden. Der Barkeeper wurde dann angerufen von, jetzt zeichne ich seinen Namen schon wieder, von MS Pro. Durch Zufall, also der wollte mich eigentlich erreichen. Und daraufhin habe ich dann per Twitter eine Nachricht bekommen, dass ich mal dringend mich da und da melden solle, mein iPhone sei gefunden worden.
Verstehe.
Per Twitter.
Ach, das ist ja eine romantische Geschichte.
Jetzt habe ich mein iPhone wieder.
Gut.
Total. Naja, stimmt, ist jetzt nicht so. Habt ihr von diesem Android-Bug gehört?
Dass man eine Rootshell kriegt.
Ja, und zwar wie man die kriegt. Dass man sie nicht erst kriegt, dass man sie hat eigentlich.
Nee, nicht so genau gelesen, weil...
Ich habe es gelesen und ich konnte es nicht glauben.
Das konnte niemand glauben, der es gelesen hat, oder?
Das musst du dir mal vorstellen. Also dieses Teil bootet, läuft und korrigiere mich. Ich habe nur so ein bisschen was drüber gelesen, aber wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe, ist es so, dass egal wo du was tippst, also ob du eine SMS tippst oder ob du irgendeinen Text in irgendein Programm, also jeglicher Text-Input, sozusagen direkt ab dem Keyboard abgegriffen, läuft nicht nur in das jeweilige Programm, was du bedienst, sondern auch im Hintergrund auch noch direkt in eine Root-Bash.
Das wird ausgefüllt.
Direkt in eine Shale.
Das ist, wenn ich dir eine SMS schicke mit Reboot, dann wird gerebooted.
Genau.
Really? Und wenn ich einem eine SMS sende mit Reboot drin?
Nee, dann nicht.
Es geht um den Keyboard-Input.
Aber es gibt also, es gibt diesen Reboot-Fall, dass jemand so, hey, blablabla, Reboot. So sah sein Telefon aus.
Also keine Ahnung, was sie da getrieben hat.
Das ist bestimmt so ein Debugging-Feature, was einer vergessen hat auszuschalten.
Also es ist wohl über irgendein RC-Fall, was man relativ leicht, also genau so Debug-Einstellungen, die man relativ leicht... RC-Fall?
Die haben ja RC-Falls noch?
Die haben offensichtlich RC-Falls.
Aber das Android ist ja auch eine geschlossene Plattform, oder? Verstehe ich das richtig?
Nein, es ist schon Open Source, nur dieses Google Distribution ist für Telefone und genauso geschlossen, wie das beim iPhone auch ist.
Okay, nur dass keiner die Programme kontrolliert, die da drauf eingespielt werden können.
Doch, die sind auch alle gesigned und das ist alles genauso dicht und die haben auch genauso einen Kill-Switch wie das iPhone.
Aber die zeigen halt alles im Gegensatz zu Apple.
Ich kenne jetzt Ihre Policy nicht in diesem Store. Bisher gibt es in diesem Store meines Wissens auch nur kostenlose Programme, oder? Gibt es jetzt auch schon kostenpflichtige Programme?
Das weiß ich ehrlich gesagt nicht, aber ich glaube, die hatten Infrastruktur einfach noch nicht fertig zu bezahlen und so was.
Wie auch immer, auf jeden Fall zeigt sich, dass da auch schon noch ein gewisser Weg gegangen werden muss. Und es wird sich zeigen. Ich habe mich jetzt nicht so sehr viel damit beschäftigt. Ich habe gehört, dass Batterielaufzeit jetzt nicht so mega prickelnd ist.
Das hätte mich ehrlich gesagt gewundert.
Und dass viele Leute das Telefon einfach deshalb nicht mögen, weil jeglicher Textinput eben über diese an der Seite raus leidenden Keyboard ist. Also selbst wenn du vertikale Anwendungen hast, musst du sozusagen das Telefon drehen und von der Seite eingeben, weil es halt kein On-Screen-Keyboard gibt.
Also das, worüber sich beim iPhone alle am Anfang beschwert haben, jetzt beschweren sich beim Android genau das Gegenteil, dass es das gibt. Aber die Tastatur soll auch nicht so prickelnd sein. Also ich hab gehört, man hat ja dieses Slide-Display, was so hoch geht und dann bleiben ja die Tasten kleben sozusagen. Das ist ja so ein untere Bereich, der so ein bisschen erhöht ist dann. Also die Tastatur ist ja so ein bisschen tiefer gelegen, ne? Weil die liegt ja unter dem Display. Das heißt, wenn man das Display so nach oben schiebt, hat man den Bereich, wo dieser Trackball- und Auflegen-Abnehm-Taste, die bleiben so weiterhin erhöht, sodass man zum Beispiel an die Return-Taste noch ziemlich dämlich rankommen soll. Also ein paar Hardware-Design-Fehler.
Ich erhalte eh nicht so viel von dem Slide-Out-Schnickes.
Also wirklich eingeschlagen ist es ja auch irgendwie nicht das Telefon, oder? So richtig eingeschlagen.
Nö, irgendjemand hat mal behauptet, Sie würden ja eine anderthalb Millionen Vorbestellungen haben. Das war wohl eine totale Ente. Glaubt habe ich das sowieso nicht. Und keine Ahnung. Also es werden jetzt wohl auch bald neue Phones rauskommen, aber es zeigt sich jetzt schon das Problem. Das Problem ist, Google verkauft keine Telefone. Google bietet die Dienstleistung der Bereitstellung eines Betriebssystems für Telefone. Und ich weiß auch nicht, was sie dafür nehmen. Also wie viel Geld sie von HTC dafür nehmen, dass Google ihnen das da drauf macht.
Ich glaube nichts. Ist doch open source angeblich.
Open source heißt nicht, dass die Dienstleistung nichts kostet. Das heißt nur, dass der Code frei ist.
Okay, man könnte daraus eine Dienstleistung machen, aber ich nehme an, da werden sie schon... Also Google hat ja eine Trasse dran, das Betriebssystem möglichst weit zu verbreiten. Ich glaube nicht, dass die Dienstleistung oder das Betriebssystem als ihr Geschäftsmodell ansehen.
Ja gut, aber das kostet Geld. Und wenn da jetzt ein Telefonhersteller ein Betriebssystem bekommt und du also angenommen, du würdest denen jetzt sozusagen ein Open Source Betriebssystem bereitstellen und sich dann irgendwie noch mit ihren ganzen Technikern die ganze Zeit abzustimmen und auf ihre Sonderwünsche einzugehen, dass dann auch noch kostenlos oben drauf formen sollten sie das machen. Das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen. Wie auch immer das geregelt ist, sicherlich haben sie derzeit die Pinke, solche Sachen zu machen. Nur ihr Interesse ist halt eigentlich nur so diese Verbreitung. Ihr Interesse ist nicht wirklich daran, dass da jetzt ein besonders gutes Telefon dabei rauskommt.
Was ist dann aber deren Interesse? Also nur Verbreitung kann es ja auch nicht sein.
Naja, aber damit es sich verbreitet, muss es gut sein.
Der Interesse ist, dass das Web-Development-Modell als Entwicklungsmodell Verbreitung findet, dass sie ihre Anwendung Verbreitung finden. Das ist ihr primäres Interesse. Eine Alternative zu Windows Mobile zu sein.
Ja, Windows Mobile, gutes Stichwort. Das Windows Mobile 7 wurde verschoben auf Ende nächsten Jahres, habe ich richtig verstanden. Und deswegen kommt wohl erst mal eine Version 6.5 nachgeschoben. Weil 7 soll dann mit Touch-Features sein, natürlich.
Sie sind doomed. Also es ist vorbei. Ich sag's ja schon seit zwei Jahren, aber mir hört ja keiner zu. Aber es ist vorbei mit Microsoft. Doch. Doch. Also im Telefonbereich ist es voll vorbei. Sie verkaufen weniger Lizenzen als Apple. Naja, okay, das ist noch nicht durch. Aber ich sag, Ende des Jahres wird es soweit sein. Und die haben nix.
Dann kommt der große Showdown.
Also im Telefonbereich ist es wirklich erst mal schwer. Aber ich find's ja ganz erstaunlich, welchen Wirbel sie jetzt wieder um Windows 7 zu machen schaffen.
Ja, das ist Nebelkerzer.
Ja, aber noch funktioniert's offensichtlich. Also noch sagen alle, das sieht auf den ersten Blick gar nicht so scheiße aus wie bisher.
Bitte, hast du dieses Video gesehen?
Welches?
Wo sie das previewen.
Jaja, klar.
Das sieht nicht scheiße aus. Das sieht voll scheiße aus. Das ist scheiße. Windows 7 ist Vista mit einer Zahl anstatt einem Wort. Das handelt sich bei Windows 7 technisch um Windows Vista. Es handelt sich nicht um ein neues Betriebssystem. Es ist dasselbe. Alles, was sie machen, ist, dass sie in der Oberfläche was ändern.
Nee, sie scheinen auch schon ein bisschen tiefer reinzugehen.
Ach, wo denn?
Also es soll ja wohl deutlich schneller werden.
Ach, etwas ressourcenschwimmender. Ja gut, aber innerhalb von drei Jahren sollten sie das mit Vista auch geschafft haben.
Natürlich ist das nur der neue Name.
Das könnten sie auch nach wie vor Vista SP3 nennen.
Habt ihr nicht gelesen auf Slashdot gestern oder vorgestern? Ja gestern hat ein Typ das neue Windows 7 getestet gegen Vista. Weil sie sagen ja, Windows 7 soll irgendwie schneller sein und so. Und da gibt es ja auch welche Betas schon. Und hat das getestet und die waren beide gleich schnell.
Es ist Vista.
Also sie sagen halt nur, wir kümmern uns jetzt um Speed. Bei Snow Leopard machen sie ja gerade den gleichen Trick. Aber es ist halt eigentlich alles gleich schnell. Wahrscheinlich ist Snow Leopard auch gar nicht besser schneller als der alte Leopard.
Es ist deshalb schneller, weil die Computer in drei Jahren oder vier Jahren, wenn sie es dann wirklich mal releasen, schneller sind. Sie verkaufen es dann bloß nicht mehr unter dem Namen Vista.
Also noch ist es ja sowieso viel zu früh, sich darüber irgendwelche Gedanken zu machen, weil noch ist es ja nicht fertig. Aber was ich gesehen habe, was so einen Bass erzeugt haben, was so Heise geschrieben hat, was Gizmodo schreibt, was so die üblichen Verdächtigen alle schreiben, ist doch, nachdem ja Vista wirklich ja auch teilweise schon durchaus ungerechtigt in die Fresse gekriegt hat, ist doch jetzt eher so ein Verhalten, ach ja, mal gucken, was da kommt. So schlecht sieht es ja erstmal gar nicht aus. Das ist so das Pressefeedback, was ich einfach so sehe. Und insofern glaube ich, dass das ja auch ein bisschen...
Na, alle denken jetzt, dass man Vista ja nur noch aufwärts gehen kann.
Betriebssystem ist zehn Prozent Code und 90 Prozent Psychologie.
Kann es schlimmer werden für Microsoft?
Naja, sagen wir so sehen, nach wie vor eines der reichsten Konzerne der Welt. Insofern ist da schon noch Potenzial nach unten.
Ja, reich ist ein Ist-Zustand. Noch nicht General Motors. Sie haben noch Potenzial nach unten. General Motors. Ja, das ist aber ein interessanter Vergleich.
Das war die Geschichte mit dem, die Deutsche Bank sagt, General Motors, Kursziel 0 Dollar, war es das?
Genau. Haben Sie das gesagt?
Weil die wären Pleite und deswegen Kursziel 0 Dollar.
Selbst wenn Sie nicht Pleite geben, können Sie so lange nichts an Ihre Aktionäre auszahlen.
Ich weiß noch nicht, ob es schon so weit ist bei Microsoft. Ich glaube, dass Sie noch in einem Business sind, wo Sie noch ein bisschen länger durchhalten als jetzt General Motors mit ihren überdimensionierten SUV-Karren. Aber der Vergleich ist insofern schon ganz angemessen, dass Sie fehlen, komplett irgendeinen Zukunftsmarkt zu besetzen. Es gibt einfach nichts, was auch nur halbwegs nach Trend aussieht, wo Sie derzeit nennenswerte Fortschritte machen. Ja, Spielekonsolen, was haben Sie da? Sie haben die Xbox und Sie verdienen damit aber kein nennenswertes Geld.
Aber ich kann mir vorstellen, dass Sie über die Services, über kurzer lang Geld verdienen.
Soft kann sich das auch vorstellen, dass Sie irgendwann mal irgendwie Geld verdienen. Aber mit irgendwann mal irgendwie Geld verdienen bist du halt nicht die Nummer eins, sondern die Nummer eins bist du, wenn du halt richtig Kohle machst.
Ja, aber du hast gerade gefragt, sie sind nun kein und Xbox definitiv sind soweit vorne.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das Xbox-Modell wirklich noch so die Zukunft ist. Ob das wirklich der große Markt ist, diese überdimensionierten, großen, schweren, mit fetten Lüftern und lahmenden Lüftern ausgestatteten Geräte.
Na ja, das werden Sie hoffentlich irgendwann mal ein bisschen kleiner hinkriegen. Aber ich, so dieses, dass man sich darüber Videos ausleihen kann, über das Ding und das Home-PC.
Die Xbox machen die da nicht auch Verluste?
Ja, aber die Leute, die sich eine Xbox kaufen, die wollen doch keine Videos ausleiten.
Ich glaube, darauf wird es hingehen. Klar, wie geht in die Richtung? Also, die Nintendo, da kann man sich keine Videos ausleihen, sondern das ist eher so sozusagen nicht für die Hardcore-Spieler, mehr die Konsole, sondern auch für die Casual Gamer.
Ja, aber das ist ja genau das, was Microsoft nicht adressiert.
Als auch, na doch, da gehen Sie ja hin in den Bereich mit diesem Xbox Live Zeug und die machen jetzt ja auch dieses neue User-Interface, an dem Sie seit Ewigkeiten, wie heißt das, New Xbox Experience oder so, an dem Sie seit Ewigkeiten rumbasteln und Videos ausleihen.
Na ja, ich äußere mich nicht, wir sind auch kein Gaming-Podcast und ich hab von GameEarly auch keine Ahnung. Ich weiß nur Sony, Playstation und Xbox, das sind halt einfach die Plattformen, die gehen in Hardcore-Gamer. Das ist ihr Markt und das war bisher auch immer ein großer Markt und das wird auch ein gewisser großer Markt bleiben. Bloß traue ich potenziell dem Markt, den die V adressiert, noch sehr viel mehr zu und machen ja auch derzeit mehr Geld damit. Beziehungsweise sie verdienen überhaupt erstmal Geld mit ihren Geräten. Sie verkaufen zum Beispiel Geräte, wo sie mit dem Gerät selber schon Geld verdienen. Das ist ein großer Unterschied zu Sony und Microsoft. Aber wir waren bei Windows 7, was uns auch schon von irgendeinem anderen interessanten Thema abgebracht hat. Genau, Windows Mobile, was ja dann auch 7. Also ich glaube, das ist so ein bisschen die Idee. Sie wollen wieder diese Illusion erzeugen. Das wäre ja jetzt alles sozusagen dasselbe, so wie mit OS X. Ja, Windows 7, Windows Mobile 7, so eine Vereinfachung in der Marketing-Geschichte. Und vor allem, sie wollen halt das V-Wert loswerden. So, und deswegen behaupten sie jetzt und machen halt wieder so Ankündigungsware. Das ist ja Announcementware. Ich frage mich ja schon, wie man sowas überhaupt durchziehen kann. Jetzt haben sie uns zwei Jahre lang versucht, oder anderthalb Jahre lang versucht, dieses Vista zu verkaufen. Zuletzt gnadenlos gescheitert. Der komplette Fail auch wieder mit dieser Werbekampagne. Also schlechter hätte man es ja wohl kaum machen können. Absoluter Epic Fail.
Gibt es eigentlich die IMPC-Kampagne noch?
Nobody cares, ob die nun läuft oder rumfällt, sagen wir Melum. Ich würde sagen, Ihr Fortschritt, den Sie auf Ihren Märkten gemacht haben, ist gleich Null.
Von diesen Seinfeld-Videos gab es eigentlich noch mehr.
Angeblich gab es noch einen dritten.
Einen dritten? Ich hab nur den ersten geguckt.
Der zweite, das ist ja überhaupt das Lustigste. Diese Seinfeld-Sachen, die waren wirklich interessant zu gucken. Das war wirklich crazy. Das war wirklich, vor allem dieses zweite Teil, fand ich irre crazy.
Das war beim ersten auch ziemlich schlecht, aber es machte erst Sinn, als dann der zweite kam.
Sinn hat es noch nicht gemacht. Der zweite war ja noch mal ganz anders. Das war, wo sie dann bei dieser Familie zu Hause waren.
Wie, hat das Sinn entdeckt?
Ja, doch, ein bisschen. Ja, schon.
Na, es hat super Interesse erzeugt. Das ganze Internet hat nur von diesen Spots geredet und Podcasts haben sich stundenlang darüber ausgelassen, was das denn nun alles zu bedeuten hätte. Das ist ein Erfolg. Weil diese eine PC-Geschichte, ich fand's nicht schlecht. Ich fand die zweite sogar richtig unterhaltsam. Und ich glaube, die Sache ist einfach so gelaufen. Sie sind irgendwie an diesen Seinfeld mal geraten. Oder an irgendjemand anderes, der ihnen klar gemacht hat, dass sie jetzt auch mal ein bisschen Profil zeigen müssen. Dass sie sich mal was trauen müssen. Dass sie mal was anderes machen. Dann haben sie gesagt, oh ja, geil, super, da schmeißen wir jetzt Geld drauf. Jetzt sind wir auch cool. Haben sich diesen Seinfeld ins Boot geholt. Und der, das würde ich jetzt mal sagen von dem, was ich, ich kenn zwar jetzt die Seinfeld-Serie, ist nicht so gut, aber das, was ich da gesehen habe, das war halt Strange Comedy. Das waren keine Werbespots, die jetzt versucht haben, ganz platt nur irgendeine Marketing-Floske rauszuhusten, sondern da wurde etwas konstruiert, was den Leuten im Hirn rumspinnt.
Ja, aber sagen wir's mal so, bei Seinfeld war das damals lustig.
Ich fand das, ich fand das, ich fand das unterhaltsam. Ich fand die zweite Sache richtig unterhaltsam.
Das erste war, die lernen sich kennen.
Das erste war das erste.
Das macht allein auch keinen Sinn. Das macht ja Sinn mit dem zweiten zusammen.
Allein diese Situation, Jerry Seinfeld und Bill Gates sitzen bei irgendeiner anderen Familie. Dann mit dieser crazy Oma, die irgendwie da durch den Flur latscht und irgendwie, ich weiß nicht mehr ganz genau, ich muss mir das nochmal anschauen, aber es war einfach so verrückt, dass ich mir dachte, geil. Das wäre jetzt auch echt mal die Zukunft für Bill Gates, einfach in so einer Soap-Opera auszuharen. Und dann Schluss. Dann haben sie einfach den Mut verloren, haben sich einfach durch die Kritik, die irgendwie los hagelt und die jetzt erstmal auch, sagen wir mal, so ein bisschen blind auf Microsoft einschlug.
Definitiv.
Haben sie den Schiss bekommen, haben dann die dritte, die wahrscheinlich alles wunderbar aufgelöst hätte, die irgendwie ein großartiges Finale hatte. Gut, vielleicht war es auch besonders bekloppt und deswegen haben sie es weggelassen. Ich weiß es nicht. Das haben sie auf jeden Fall weggelassen. Dann haben sie den größten Fehler gemacht, den man überhaupt machen kann, dass sie sich als Nummer eins auf den Spot der Nummer zwei einlassen. Und dann irgendwie so, nee, sind wir ja nicht. Wir sind ja stolz darauf, Computer zu sein. Wobei das mit diesem einmal PC alles bestätigt und nochmal umdreht, was Apple ja immer gesagt hat. Das ist einfach, ja, wir sind alle durchschnittlich. Das war das, was bei diesen einmal PC-Spots für mich rüberkam.
Dabei ist eigentlich ja Microsofts...
Wir sind alle PC, wir sind alle gleich. Wir sind alle Individual. Richtig.
Microsofts Größe war doch aber eigentlich, dass sie die Sache anfangen und die dann irgendwie über Jahre durchziehen, richtig Geld reinbuttern und egal, was die alle sagen, sie sagen, es ist schlecht und es ist scheiße, dass sie so lange dranbleiben, so penetrant den Markt sozusagen bombardieren mit ihren Produkten, bis es irgendwann halt greift. Und genau das haben sie bei ihrem Spot irgendwie sich nicht getraut. Da hätten sie auch einfach mal penetrant irgendwie weiter Geld reinbuttern sollen und irgendwann wär es angekommen, glaube ich.
Das glaube ich auch. Ich glaube, dass das wirklich, das hätte wirklich einen Unterschied machen können.
Also deine Theorie, dass der dritte Teil von dem Spot so sagenhaft scheiße war, dass sie sich lieber den Spot ausgesetzt haben und es vor den Steckerzügen haben.
Oder sagenhaft gut. Also es kann auch sein, dass der total toll gewesen ist, dass sie es bloß nicht verstanden haben. Ich kann mir vorstellen, dass die Intelligenz von dem Seinfeld das Eigenverständnis der Microsoft-Marketing-Abteilung einfach überschritten hat. Und dann war einfach der Punkt gekommen, wo sie alle Angst hatten. Und die haben einfach keine Eier gehabt, um diese Geschichte durchzuziehen.
Ich behaupte einfach, der dritte Teil war so sagenhaft. Ich meine, Jerry Seinfeld...
So sagenhaft was?
So scheiße, dass es den niemand mehr senden wollte. Hast du mal B-Movie gesehen? Das ist so ein Film, in dem Jerry Seinfeld die Rolle einer Biene spricht. Das ist einer der schlechtesten Filme, den du jemals gesehen hast.
Hast du denn das mit der Familie gesehen, mit dem Seinfeld?
Ja.
Oder das fandest du doof?
Ich hatte mir noch nicht so richtig eine Meinung. Ich fand es eher nicht so doll. Ich kann mir vorstellen, dass hätten sie es weiter aufgebaut.
Ich fand das super, es hat super Spannung erzeugt. Alle saßen da und dachten sich, Alter Falter, die Jungs sitzen jetzt bei dieser Familie. What happens next? Und so einen Cliffhanger zu erzeugen, das ist schon mal wirklich großartig.
Also der Cliffhanger hat bei mir nicht so wirklich funktioniert. Ich hab's mir angeguckt, unter der Prämisse mal gucken, was sie jetzt machen bei Microsoft. Dafür war es erstmal so, weil ich dachte, oh mein Gott, oh mein Gott, was machen sie?
Ja, aber wenn Teil drei rausgekommen wäre, da hättest du irgendwie dein YouTube-Window aufgemacht, hättest du erst mal Popcorn geholt. Siehst du mal, naja, was will man denn mehr?
Also ich hätt's mir gegeben, ja klar.
Also wir werden das nicht auflösen können, wir stellen fest, wir sind unterschiedlicher Meinung, was diese Werbung betrifft, aber wir sind vielleicht einer Meinung, was Windows 7 betrifft.
Aber was bei Windows 7, das ist, was mir da aufgefallen ist, ist ein kleines Detail am Rand, und zwar haben Sie dann noch mal in einer Demo die Taskbar gezeigt, die neue, unten dieses Startmenü, und dann sagt auch tatsächlich der Präsentator im Vorfeld so, ja ja, Leute, die die gesehen haben, behaupten, wir hätten bei einem anderen Betriebssystem geklaut. Und ich briskiere jetzt mir meinen Job, wenn ich das sage, ja, ihr habt Recht, wir haben bei Windows XP geklaut. Das ist aber eine komplette Lüge, das ist wirklich das Doc. Die haben das Doc geklaut.
Aber das Doc ist doch von einer Startbar geklaut.
Aber der Ansatz, und zwar ist das ja bisher immer so gewesen, dass bei Windows ist ja alles immer fensterbasiert gewesen. Das heißt, wenn man von einem Programm zwei Fenster offen hatte, dann hatte man unten in diesem Menü zwei Buttons drin. Und mit Windows 7 wird das so sein, dass die programbasiert zusammengefügt werden, die Fenster. Das heißt, dass die Programme von einem Fenster unter einem Programm eiken.
Weil die Leute heutzutage so viele Programme und Fenster offen haben, dass da unten gar nicht mehr alles vernünftig hingepasst hat, oder?
Na das geht ja schon ewig lange, dass sie das angefangen haben zusammenzufügen. Aber jetzt ist es so, dass von Anfang an, wenn du zwei Internet Explorer Fenster aufhast, hast du trotzdem nur ein Internet Explorer eiken da unten. Und wenn du da mit der Maus rüber gehst, dann, das ist relativ wisch gemacht, dann hast du so ein Preview der Fenster und kannst da dann die Fenster schließen und so was. Das ist relativ gut gelungen. Aber ich glaube, die haben mit dieser neuen Taskbar da unten wirklich so eine Art Paradigmenwechsel durchgeführt. Weg von der dokumentbasierten Ansicht sozusagen oder zentrierten Ansicht hin zur Antikation.
Also von Paradigmenwechsel würde ich nicht sprechen, wenn Sie da so ein bisschen User Interface Tweaking machen. Weiß ja gar ja, was da wieder für eine grauenhafte Vergewaltigung der Realität dahinter stattfindet, um diesen Effekt so zu erzeugen. Aber Windows rettet sich nicht dadurch, dass Sie ihren Start-Bahn überarbeiten. Das ist einfach Kosmetik.
Ich sag da auch gar nicht, dass das jetzt irgendwie, dass das jetzt...
Du sagst nicht, dass es Microsoft retten könnte.
Ich sag nicht, dass es Microsoft rettet. Du sagst nur, Sie haben es geklaut. Ich finde es als Phänomen ganz interessant, dass es wirklich, dass es transparent ist. Es sieht aus wie das Doc. Sie sprechen sogar noch an.
Das ist doch nichts Neues, dass Sie bei Apple sich Ihre Ideen abholen.
Ja, aber das Sie vorher noch erwähnen. Haha, ja, das sieht aus wie das Doc. Nee, das sieht nicht aus. Doch, doch. Ihr habt es geklaut, gibts zu.
Wer erwähnt das?
Wie gesagt, in diesem Tech-Talk erwähnen Sie ja... Ja, ja, mir wurde gesagt, das sieht aus wie bei einem gewissen anderen Betriebssystem.
Ein Tech-Talk von Microsoft.
Ein Tech-Talk von Microsoft sagt das.
Er wollte witzig sein.
Ja, aber er hat versehentlich die Wahrheit gesagt.
Ja, das ist wahrscheinlich wie dieser Nokia-Entwickler, den ich da auf dieser Web2.0-Konferenz gesehen habe.
Meinst du, der hat seine Bewerbung schon abgeschickt?
Ich weiß nicht. Aber nachdem ich... Also, die Präsentation von Apple jetzt nochmal auf diesen iPhone-Tech-Talk jetzt am Montag hier zu sprechen zu kommen, das war professionell. Also, du stehst ja, so präsentiert man seine Plattform. Die haben einfach BAM, BAM, BAM, die Sache klar gemacht. Hier ist die Plattform. Das ist das, worauf ihr achten muss. Hervorragende Slides, alles super erklärt. Klar, man hätte noch mehr in die Tiefe gehen können, wissen die auch, war für Einsteiger. Aber es war einfach schlüssig, dargelegt, genau gezeigt. Alle Tools funktionierten auch. Und diese Nokia-Handsets sitzen da vorne und meinen halt, wenn er uns nachher irgendwie einen Schnaps ausgibt, dann erzählen wir euch auch die Wahrheit. Das ist sowieso der Unterschied. Also es wird, glaube ich, im nächsten Jahr, ich bin mittlerweile überzeugt, dass Apple Nokia ablösen wird von Platz 1. Im Umsatz.
Und ich würde jetzt normalerweise wieder sprechen.
Nächstes Jahr schon.
Nächstes Jahr, es ist schon durch.
Du willst also mal wieder wetten. Warte, warte, jetzt müssen wir ihn fest nageln. Du willst also wieder wetten. Machen wir das zusammen?
Ich guck mal, ich hab...
Also Nokia ist schon noch ein paar Nummern größer.
Ja, aber ich meine...
Und zwar ein paar Nummern.
Aber im Augenblick mit dem dritten Quartal...
Wie vielfach?
Weniger als dreifach.
Weniger als dreifach. Der Apple war bei 20... 4,6. Der Apple war bei 4,6 und Nokia war bei 21 Milliarden. 12?
Wir sind durch. Und die verlieren. Nokia hat gerade 3000 Leute entlassen. Die haben diverse Forschungslabs ausgelöst.
Also diese NPD-Gruppe hat ja... Die sind durch. Damit hatte ich nicht... Das war ja quasi eigentlich unsere Wette, die wir hatten, an die ich nicht geglaubt habe. Und jetzt ist es später doch eingetreten. Zwar für Amerika, aber immerhin. Im dritten Quartal hat das iPhone, war das meistverkaufte Telefon, überhaupt in Amerika?
Und meine Wette war Smartphone.
Na ja, wie gesagt, du hast es aufgeschrieben.
Das haben die Telefone der anderen Hersteller irgendwie einzeln aufteilt deswegen, richtig? Weil die so viele Modelle haben.
Ja, aber das hat das Razer geschlagen. Das Motorola Razer. Das kannst du wahrscheinlich in Amerika aus dem Zigaretten- oder aus dem Cargoumi-Automaten ziehen. Also wirklich so ein...
Es ist das amerikanische Kettensägen-Massaker. Die machen die fertig.
Ich hab ja so ein Telefon, was jeder hat. Das ist dir noch nicht aufgefallen?
Ja, das war bemerkenswert auf der Veranstaltung.
Jeder MacBook, MacBook Pro, oder?
Ich hab keinen Windows-Rechner gesehen.
Aber man hat ganz selten Nokia-Telefonklingeln hören.
Es gab ein paar Leute, die hatten noch kein iPhone.
Oder die hatten sich den Nokia-Klingelton aus Spaß aufs iPhone drauf gespielt.
Das wär doch mal eine schöne Sache.
Aber ich hab gehört, dass der Netzzugriff im Saal für die Leute, die T-Mobile hatten, saumäßig war. Da waren 300 iPhones in einem Raum. Kannst du dir vorstellen, was da abgegeben war?
Das Netz war einfach überlastet?
Naja, ich meine, wenn da so eine Zelle kommt, dann kommen dann so 300 iPhones und alle haben da irgendwie Safari am Start und flicken da rum.
Ich konnte mir das gerade Betty vorzustellen, wieso die Zelle vorbeikommt so...
Genau.
Und wir waren ja bei O2 eingebucht. Und jetzt kann ich gleich mal nochmal einschieben. Ich hatte jetzt das erste Mal Edge-Connectivity mit O2.
In der U-Bahn.
In der U-Bahn. Und verschiedene Leute haben mir jetzt hier per Twitter auch davon berichtet, dass sie auch auf dem Land irgendwo Autobahn auch Edge hatten. Und dann habe ich Nink geschickt bekommen und da stand, was ich komplett übersehen hatte, dass schon im März angekündigt wurde, dass sie jetzt langsam ihr Netz umstellen auf Edge.
Das heißt, dass sie auch bald Edge haben, weil ich habe ja kein UMTS.
Da wo sie GSM haben, ja vor allem.
Also das wird nicht überall... Also hier in der Stadt kann es knicken, weil hier gibt es ja überall UMTS, wo du dir findest, ein UMTS-iPhone. Aber in Bereichen wo sie kein UMTS haben, wollen sie vermehrt auf Edge umbauen.
Na klar, man darf es ja Edge auch da.
Ich habe jemandem geholfen, der ist aus Amerika wieder gekommen, sein iPhone zu hacken, per iChat. Und der war auch gerade irgendwo in der Pampa und hat dann live berichtet, oh und sogar Edge hat er! Ich war ganz glücklich darüber.
Ich hoffe, ich habe auch bald Edge.
Wieso solltest du, ach so.
Ich habe kein U-M-T-S.
Ach so, du hast ja noch kein 3G-Telefon.
Deswegen habe ich GPRS und Edge. Edge wäre eigentlich schon total okay, weil U-M-T-S, so viel Speed brauche ich gar nicht.
Mensch, Ravox, wie hast du denn dieses Kinderbildchen dahingetrickt in dem Chat?
Kinderbildchen?
Ja, ich hab das auch, du.
Was ist denn für ein Kinderbildchen?
Kindskopf. Wollt ihr gleich erzählen?
Ihr habt Smileys eingeschaltet?
Ach, das ist ein Smiley, kann sein.
Jaja, das ist irgendwie Karee-Karee.
Ich suche Kinder-Pornos-Smiley.
Was heißt denn das? Was ist denn das für ein Bildchen? Ach, so eine Torte oder was? So ein Manga-Mädel oder was kommt da?
Ich hab keine Ahnung, ist zu klein.
Was soll denn das heißen, Manga-Mädel? Verstehe ich nicht, Ravox. Anyway, ich hab einen Pick, wie man so schön sagt. Was? Na, eine Empfehlung. Und zwar gibt es ein Tool fürs iPhone, das heißt iPhone Backup Extractor. Und das schnappt sich dein Backup im iTunes, was von deinem Telefon gemacht wurde.
Also auf dem Rechner, also auf dem Software?
Genau, auf dem Mac. Also kommt hoch mit dem User-Interface und zeigt dir dann quasi die Sandboxes von allen Programmen, die du installiert hast, an. Und dann kannst du sagen, das hätte ich gerne ausgepackt. Und dann macht er dir ein Folder und packt die Dateien aus. Was natürlich ein super cooles Feature ist. Ich stelle mir gerade mal vor, das gäbe es als Framework. Dann könntest du darüber halt super Syncing machen. Diese ganzen Anwendungen, mit denen ich jetzt hier Audio-Recording gemacht habe, die müssen sich ja mühen, das irgendwie auf den Rechner zu kriegen. Griffin hat eine komplette Anwendung geschrieben für den Mac, mit der das dann empfängt. Die anderen machen das halt über einen Webbrowser. Das heißt, sie starten dann Web-Server auf dem iPhone mit Bonjour und dann kannst du mit dem Safari darauf zugreifen, das runterladen und so ne Sachen. Und so konnte ich jetzt einfach von dem Recording-Programm, weiß gar nicht mehr, ich hab da mehrere installiert, aber ist auch egal, es funktioniert bei allen gleich. Da liegt ja dann quasi das aufgenommene File, also das AIFF in der Regel, in der Sandbox und so konnte ich die dann einfach direkt auspacken. Das heißt, ich brauch eigentlich nur was aufnehmen, dann das iPhone anschließen, dann macht der ein aktuelles Backup, dann geh ich mit diesem iPhone-Backup-Extraktor da ran und sag hier von dem Programm zeig mir mal die Sandbox und dann hab ich alle Dateien. Dann hat mir das iTunes das schon rübergezogen. Ohne irgendwie Webserver-Schnickes und Gedöns. Und so findet man dann halt auch Sachen wieder, weil man ja nicht weiß, welches Programm jetzt eigentlich wie viel Platz belegt. Man kriegt ja vom iTunes nur angezeigt, wie viel Platz die Programme überhaupt belegen, aber nicht welches Programm wie viel.
Bei dem Xcode gibt es ja auch in diesem Organizer so eine Auflistung der Programme. Und bei allen Programmen, die man selber drauf installiert hat über das Xcode, also bei meinem eigenen, kann man das aufklappen und dann sieht man da drin sozusagen die Sandbox, dann kann man sich die auch von Xcode irgendwo hin speichern lassen, damit man sozusagen seinen Content, den man auf dem iPhone speichert, auch debuggen kann. Bloß dieses Tool macht es halt für anscheinend für alle Programme und nicht nur für die, die man selber eingespielt hat.
Genau. Genau. Du kannst einfach aus dem Backup einfach alles heraus machen. Das fände ich ja super. Ich denke immer noch, ein kommendes Update sollte so eine Syncing-Funktion einbauen. Programme sollten die Möglichkeit haben, auf Mac und auf Windows quasi über das Syncing von iTunes auf Inhalte zuzugreifen. Dass man quasi diese Sandbox zur Verfügung stellt.
Bestimmt, aber dann nur mit MobileMe-Account.
Nee, das muss ohne gehen. Das wird gehen. Das schaffen die noch irgendwann.
Das war jetzt...
Na, es gibt Programme, die das ja über MobileMe machen. Also OmniFocus synkt halt unter anderem auch über MobileMe, aber haben jetzt halt auch so eine Bonjour-Lokal-Syncing-Methode eingebaut, weil Leute das halt haben wollen.
Ja, dann würden jetzt, wenn Apple sich nicht drum kümmert, heißt es, dass alle Programme anfangen, selber sich ihr Netzwerk, Schnittstellen, also die Kommunikation selber irgendwie zu machen.
Sie fangen ja nicht erst an.
Sie machen es ja schon. Ja, aber es ist blöd, wenn alle Programme das selber machen müssen. Da sollte Apple schon den Leuten ein bisschen entgegenkommen.
Nee, das finde ich auch.
Ja, und übers WLAN sollten sie auch mal synchronisieren. Das ist so komplett albern, dass man nicht über das WLAN synchronisieren kann.
Also die drei Adressen, die da neu gekommen sind, was mich auch wundert, ich muss jetzt ein bisschen ablässern, was mich wundert ist, dass ich mache an meinem Telefon keine Änderung, also nichts Großartiges, schließe es an iTunes an und der braucht also mindestens immer eine halbe Minute, ist jetzt nicht so schlimm, aber es nervt halt, eine halbe Minute, um rauszufinden, dass sich nichts geändert hat und das finde ich, das muss nicht sein.
Hattest du mal die Firmware 2.0 drauf? Da hat das teilweise Stunden gedauert, um festzustellen, dass sich nichts geändert hat.
Ja, da hatte ich noch nicht so viel Content drauf. Aber ich finde, rauszufinden, dass sich nichts geändert hat, müsste ein bisschen schneller gehen.
Also bei mir ändert sich regelmäßig fast und so schon, dass es okay ist.
Na gut, genug gelästert.
Max, wolltest du mir nicht noch was fragen? Du erinnerst dich gar nicht mehr, ne? Wir wollten ja noch über meine Maschine reden.
Das müssen wir hinten rausfäden lassen.
Genau, damit die Leute dann auswachsen können.
Das Beste zum Schluss?
Ich gehe dann nämlich vorher schon mal. Ich könnte das dann so zweit machen. Aber wir können ein bisschen über Snow Leopard noch labern, oder?
Ja, können wir.
Können wir denn? Ich weiß gar nicht.
Hast du Neuigkeiten?
Ja, ich hab da, also es gab ja vor, wann war es? Zwei, drei Wochen gab es eine neue Snow Leopard-Version, wo die auch gesagt haben, wir hatten schon drüber berichtet, wo ein Cocoa-Finer dabei ist. Und die ist jetzt draußen, die ist auch schon, ist sie geleakt? Ich glaube, die ist noch nicht geleakt. Also ich hab in Pirate Bay noch nichts gesehen. Aber ich hatte die Gelegenheit, mir das mal anzugucken, ein bisschen. Und, also was auffällt, ist, dass nichts auffällt. Also der Finder ist jetzt in 64-Bit auch. Was ja bedeutet, wie wir wissen, dass er in Cocoa geschrieben ist, weil sonst würde es ja nicht gehen, weil das Carbon ja nicht nach 64-Bit gedingst ist. Und der Finder ist jetzt in 64-Bit.
Zumindest der User-Interface-Teil.
Ja, aber man merkt nichts davon. Also wirklich gar nichts. Es ist alles exakt gleich.
Genau der gleiche Scheiß.
Ja, optisch.
Und auch vom Verhalten her, von der Synchronicität her.
Von dem Verhalten her würde ich da jetzt noch nicht so viel sagen, weil ich hab so ein bisschen das Gefühl, auch dieses Quarz-Debug, was bei den Developer-Tools dabei ist. Ich darf ja drüber reden, weil die alten Developer-Tools haben das ja auch. Da kann man ja so ein bisschen Windows debuggen und so weiter und so fort. Und das Tool ist mal irgendwie richtig gepimpt worden. Und da kann man jetzt irgendwie servermäßig zwei Rechner, kann ein Rechner den anderen irgendwie grafikmäßig debuggen. Und ich glaube, jetzt geht es langsam los mit diesem Quarz-GL-Extreme. Wie ist das, was irgendwie seit 10.4 schon nicht gekommen ist? Und das geht langsam los. Und deswegen, da ruckelt es noch so ein bisschen. Und das hat der Feind da schon, weil...
Ich glaube, der Feind da ruckelt schon ein bisschen.
Ich weiß auch gar nicht mehr, wie es hieß. Hieß es GL-Extreme?
Das konnte man immer in das Quarz-Debug einschalten.
Was du meinst, ist, dass das gesamte Quarz-Rendering in der Grafikkarte stattfindet? Naja, das wäre jetzt der Zeitpunkt, wenn Sie jetzt mit Ihrem ganzen OpenCL anfangen, dann ist, ich meine, wenn Sie Ihr eigenes Framework da nicht drauf angepasst bekommen, was sonst?
Wie ist es denn eigentlich mit diesem, ich meine, bei mir in diesem Quarz-Debug gibt es ja schon seit Ewigkeiten diesen, dass ich die User-Interface Resolution hochsetzen kann. Die gibt es auch schon seit 10.4.
Und in 10.5 sollte es ein bisschen besser supported sein. Ist aber auch irgendwie nicht so richtig was geworden. Und bisher sieht es auch bei 10.6 auch noch nicht so wirklich doll viel besser aus, als dass man da so ein bisschen mit rumspielen kann.
Ich glaube, Sie müssen erst mal Carbon komplett auswerden.
Es ist halt auch die Frage, ob es wirklich was bringt, weil so ganz unlimited User Resolution, Independence, also man will auch nicht eine komplett unendliche Independence haben, weil es wird nicht irgendwann einen Bildschirm geben, der sagen wir mal 2000 dB hat. Weil das kann das Auge eh nicht. Das Auge? Das Auge hat so ein gewisses Limit, weil irgendwann ist vorbei. Da kannst du da so viele Punkte ganz dicht nebeneinersetzen.
Das ist ja auch die Atome nicht einzeln.
Dann lohnt es sich halt einfach nicht mehr. Man braucht nur ein bisschen besser machen als die Leute mit der besten Sehkraft. Und alles darüber lohnt nicht.
Aber davon sind wir doch noch klar. Aber da sind wir doch noch ein ganzes Stück weit von unten.
Na gut, aber das iPhone zeigt auf jeden Fall, dass 200 DPI schon im Bereich dessen liegt, was man auch unterstützen möchte.
Ja, also 300, 400 bestimmt auch noch. Aber sagen wir mal 1000 ist schon fragwürdig, ob sich das noch lohnt.
Denke ich auch.
Also ich kann 600 DPI beim Laserdrucker dann auch schon irgendwie nichts mehr sehen.
Also mein Mac hat offiziell 72 DPI.
Der hat schon lange keine 72 mehr.
Also der offizielle Wert ist nach wie vor 72.
Aber rechne mal aus.
Das ist halt der Punkt, das steht da immer.
Ja, aber das ist so der alte Mac-Wert. Und der Windows-Wert war immer 96, glaube ich.
Genau, und da wollen Sie aber von weg. Aber dein Bildschirm selber hat schon...
Der hat schon längst eine vielführe Auflösung. Das ist mir klar.
Und das ist halt die Diskrepanz. Sie würden das ganz gerne, wenn dein Bildschirm 100 DPI hat, dann würden Sie das auch gerne den Programm sagen. Ja. Damit ein Programm auch wirklich etwas anzeigen kann, was zum Beispiel ein Zentimeter mal ein Zentimeter groß ist. Dass man wirklich mal weiß, wie groß ein Objekt wirklich auf dem Bildschirm erscheint in dem Moment, wo man es anzeigt. Das geht natürlich nur an, wenn der Bildschirm sagt, was er für eine Auflösung hat und wenn die Programme auch was damit anfangen können.
Das ist wahrscheinlich wie bei Audio. Der Mensch kann in jungen Jahren bis 20 Kilohertz hören, später ein bisschen weniger. Deswegen nimmt man bei der CD genau doppelt so viel, damit man super die Frequenzen abbilden kann. Ich könnte mir auch bei den Pixeln, bei der DPI ungefähr, was ähnliches vorstellen, dass sie vielleicht das Doppelte nehmen, was das Auge so hinkriegt, damit man auch später dann wirklich, wenn man irgendwas dreht, skaliert, Treppchen macht, dass man davon keine Pixelchen mehr sieht. Und dann ist Ruhe. Dann kann man wirklich skalieren, wie man will.
Ja, hoffentlich.
Aber wie gesagt, davon ist noch nicht so richtig, im Snow-Left hat noch nicht so richtig viel zu sehen. Aber alles, was ich gesehen hab, was nicht 64-Bit ist, sind nur Tools, die extern sind. Auch der Safari ist da 64-Bit, alle Shell-Commandos, also einfach mal alles.
Was sagt iTunes?
Bis auf iTunes war auch nicht 64-Bit.
Also mit anderen Worten, es tut sich so einiges. Es könnte zweierlei bedeuten. Es könnte bedeuten, dass sich nichts ändert.
Na doch, 64-Bit ist ja an sich schon mal nicht so verkehrt.
Ja, es könnte auch sein, dass sie irgendwas in der Hinterhand gerade entwickeln im Finder, von dem wir nichts sehen. Aber da sie nur schon angekündigt haben, keine Features zu haben, ruhen sie sich wahrscheinlich darauf auch aus.
Das ist Marketing, ich glaube, ziemlich schlau, weil alle sagen, so Vista, ja, so viele Features und das ist alles so langsam, brauchst du so dicke Rechner, wollen wir nicht. Und Apple hört sich das Geheule kurz an und denkt sich, alles klar, da wissen wir ja, was wir rausbringen, was keine Features hat, was irgendwie schneller ist und unten drunter schick aufgeräumt und aber nicht so mit Features voll.
Also sie werden nicht keine Features haben.
Genau, sie machen genau die gleiche Arbeit wie immer. Sie vermarkten es halt nur anders. Das ist halt das Coole. Und das ist ja das, was Microsoft jetzt auch eigentlich macht. Sie sagen ja bei Windows 7, wir kümmern uns jetzt um, dass es schneller, tollerer und mehr stabil ist und so. Und die machen aber auch die gleiche Arbeit.
Ja, genau, sie machen das Gegenteil eigentlich.
Ja, andersrum. Also sie holen, wir müssen jetzt das fixen.
Sie sagen, dass es schneller ist, aber sie werden da nicht viel dran... Ich weiß nicht, ob sie da viel dran drehen können. Sie meinen ja, sie würden es auf Netbooks zum Laufen bekommen. Das halte ich aber zunächst einmal auch nur für eine Behauptung. Anyway, lass uns nicht bei Windows hängen bleiben.
Aber will ich noch eine kleine Anekdote erzählen zu dem 64-Bit? Ich bin ja hier so ein Transmission-Fan und hänge ja da auch immer im Irk-Channel rum. Und nachdem ich mir dann dieses Snow-Lab mal so ein bisschen angeguckt habe und habe ich auch gesehen, dass Transmission ja dann auch nicht in 64-Bit läuft. Dann bin ich in den Transmission-Irk-Channel und meinte, Jungs, wie sieht es denn aus mit 64-Bit? Weil die sind ja immer so vorne am Start mit allen modernen Zeug und so. Und die so, was, 64-Bit, wer hat denn sowas? Wer braucht denn sowas? Was läuft denn schon in 64-Bit? Ich kurz in meinen Activity-Monitor geguckt. Meinte so, na alles. Auf Snow-Lab hat. Meint die, was wirklich? Echt? Und dann ging irgendwie das Gerede in diesem Channel los, was man denn machen müsste für 64-Bit, weil sie doch gerne immer so weit vorne wären. Und dann kam ich nach zwei, drei Stunden wieder rein in den Channel. Sie waren immer noch am Quatschen. Wie so angestochener Bienenschwarm, so weiß ich schon. Und dann ist es wohl so, dass die Lip-Transmission unter Linux schon in 64-Bit läuft. Nur das OS-Tenden-Gui halt noch nicht so richtig. Und das wiederum liegt eigentlich auch nur da dran, weil, also mit so Kleinigkeiten, die sie auch schon gleich noch am gleichen Tag alles geändert haben, hier so nach NS-Integer ändern und so, damit es sowohl für 32- und 64-Bit läuft. Das geht über so ein Makro. Das Grow-Framework ist wohl nicht 64-Bit-kompatibel gewesen und deswegen können sie wohl noch nicht, sonst hätten sie es noch am gleichen Tag gefixt. Also sind sie wirklich ganz fleißig dabei und ich glaube, das dauert nicht mehr lange und dann gibt es...
Ich glaube auch nicht, dass es bei Grow lange dauern wird.
Nee, da hab ich auch schon was gehört, gibt es wohl schon so ein bisschen so.
Wobei bei Grow, die hängen ja manchmal ein bisschen hinterher, hab ich das Gefühl.
Ich hab Grow immer kurz benutzt, muss ich zugeben. Ich bin ja immer so ein bisschen technikfoul teilweise. Und dieses Grow ging mir dann irgendwie auf den Keks an. Dauernd die Fenster hoch poppen und so.
Das war mir zu nervig. Also ich bin prinzipiell ein großer Freund von der Funktionell. Also von dem, dass man ein Notification Fenster hat, dass die auch schick aussehen. Aber ich finde Grow selber doch relativ doof gelöst immer. Leider.
Das ist halt so ein Aufsatz.
Ja, es ist aber nicht nur, dass es ein Aufsatz ist, sondern auch wie der Aufsatz gemacht ist, finde ich relativ doof. Also ich finde ein paar Sachen könnte man da wesentlich übersichtlicher machen und wesentlich besser und wesentlich angenehmer. Aber egal. Du hast doch ein schönes Thema hier. Apropos jetzt Fahrplan, BVG. Das wäre doch nochmal, ich glaube, da kann Tim schön schreien, oder?
Da gab es ja erst heute News, ne?
Ja, also das ist, wir haben die Applikation hier auch schon mal besprochen und gelobt.
Genau.
Von dem Jonas Witt hier auch aus Berlin.
War der eigentlich auch auf Detector?
Weiß ich nicht. Vielleicht, keine Ahnung. Ich glaube auch nicht, dass er da viel Neues mitgenommen hätte. Auf jeden Fall, ja, es gab da ein bisschen Bewegung. Also noch als wir unseren letzten Podcast aufgenommen haben, ich hätte das vergessen zu erwähnen, weil es mir irgendwie entfallen war oder so. Es gab dann ein Update dieser Applikation, in diesem Update-Text stand drin. Ich habe den Netzplan aus der Applikation herausgenommen, also dieser U-Bahn und Straßenbahnplan.
Als was ist denn eigentlich drin gewesen?
Als Bild. Naja, also was jetzt die Quelle des Bildes war, weiß ich nicht, wahrscheinlich ein PNG. Und, naja, weil er halt bei der BVG angefragt hätte, wie denn das so generell so wäre und dann mal in die so, naja, das ist aber unser Copyright oder unser Urheberrecht und so möchten wir nicht, dass ihr das verwendet. So, und dann hat er es halt rausgenommen. Dann gab es so ein bisschen Aufschrei, vor allem gestützt durch jemanden bei der Taz, dem das irgendwie nicht so richtig passte, der dann einen Artikel darüber geschrieben hat. Genau. Und dieser Artikel hat dann eine unglaubliche Welle losgetreten, bis es sogar bei Wired irgendwie war. Eigentlich so stille postmäßig. Und bei TechCrunch glaube ich auch so schöne Bilder. Ja, der Netzplan wurde von dem Programm entfernt, ansonsten war das Programm ja unverändert in seiner Funktion. Also wenn man sich diesen Netzplan nie angeschaut hat, hat man auch keinen Unterschied gemerkt. Bei WireTie ist es dann halt schon öffentlicher Nahverkehr verbietet iPhone-Applikation, wobei das schon im deutschen Blog teilweise falsch war.
Ich glaube, das war schon bei Heise dann falsch und in der Taz kam es auch immer so. Also ich meine, dann hat sich die Sprecherin wirklich dämlich ausgedrückt.
Nee, der von der Taz hat das voll geblickt.
Wir haben ja eh gelöst, das übrigens.
Und was wollte ich jetzt gerade sagen? Naja, so, dann... Ich hab auch ein bisschen darüber geblockt, dann andere haben darüber geblockt, was das doch für eine bekloppte Haltung wäre. Ja, also anstatt da einfach mal drauf zu gucken und zu sehen, oh super, da verwendet ja jemand unsere Datenbank und bietet einen Service an. Sind die halt in dieser typisch deutschen Beamtenmentalität verfangen gewesen mit, oh Gott, jetzt können wir aber schuld sein, weil hier werden falsche Auskünfte gegeben und blablabla. Ich verstehe ja, dass das so ein Ding ist und dass Sie so ein bisschen auch so qualitätsvernarrt sind. Aber ich verstehe trotzdem nicht, warum Sie das nicht eher als Gelegenheit ansehen.
Na ja, es wirkte schon ein bisschen an H&R beigezogen, diese ganze Begründung.
Da hat auf jeden Fall erstmal...
Wir wollen das Beste für unsere Kunden.
Also nicht meine Halloween-Auftritte-Bahn aus.
Ja, da hat definitiv jemand eine Auskunft gegeben, der keine Ahnung hat. Da kam ja noch diese Aussage mit dem Patent. Wir haben da ja ein Patent drauf und Apple wäre ja so eine reiche Firma. Das war irgendeine Person, ich weiß gar nicht, Mann oder Frau.
Ich glaube, das war die Pressesprecherin von denen.
Ja, ich erinnere es jetzt im Detail. Ist aber nicht so wichtig. Auf jeden Fall, da hat jemand geredet, dass er weitgehend im befreiten Raum ist. Weder greift da jetzt irgendeinen Partei hin, noch hat es irgendwas mit Apple zu tun. Ich würde nie so weit gehen zu sagen, dass jetzt alle Leute, die bei der BVG arbeiten, bekloppt sind. Das ist nicht der Punkt. Da sind bestimmt eine Menge Leute, die einfach auch das Beste wollen, aber die halt in irgendeiner Form in diesem System auch scheitern. Das ist eigentlich normalerweise die Geschichte bei öffentlichen Verkehrsmitteln. Und nicht nur dort, wie wir alle wissen. Wie auch immer.
Du bist entspannt ruhig. Was ist los? Entschuldigung. Du nimmst die BVG in Schutz. Oh mein Gott. So ein bisschen.
Ich will ja jetzt auch nicht sinnlos drauf einhaken. Du hast mich gebeten, die Geschichte zu erzählen. Was mache ich jetzt?
Ich bin verwundert. Nichts weiter.
Ich hab mich in meinem Blog ein bisschen aufgeregt.
Ja, da quasi.
Naja, man muss ja auch ein bisschen überspitzen. Ja, gut, ich meine, es ist kein Geheimnis, dass ich das Web-Angebot, das digitale Angebot der BVG schon immer schlecht fand. Ich fand es zwar gut, dass sie irgendwann mal einen Online-Fahrplan bereitgestellt haben, aber zu dem Zeitpunkt, als sie das gemacht haben, war es meiner Meinung nach einfach immer noch unter ihren Möglichkeiten und vor allem unter den Bedürfnissen.
Aber ich wusste vorher nicht mehr, dass es dieses mobil.bvg.de überhaupt gibt.
Ja, das gibt es seit ein paar Monaten. Aber zum Beispiel, also das Ding ist, dass einfach da immer noch Leute am Walten sind, die nicht wirklich darüber nachdenken oder es nicht verstehen, wie man sowas benutzt. Und wenn ich das benutze, dann sitze ich hier und möchte gerne die nächste Verbindung wissen nach. Aber von zu Hause. Und ich will nicht jedes Mal wieder Greifswalder Straße slash Danziger Straße eingeben und dann noch bei der nächsten Seite nochmal vorgeschlagen bekommen, meinten Sie jetzt diese oder jene Haltestelle, weil ich irgendeinen Buchstaben falsch getippt habe? Und dann kommt vielleicht noch nicht mal die richtige Haltestelle in der Auswahlliste. Und dann muss man wieder zurückgehen und hin und her. Und dann lädt er mir immer noch 50 Spalten, sonstigen FU und tausend Links von Sachen, die mich einfach überhaupt nicht interessieren. Und es dauert ewig. Und das Ganze dann mobil ging gar nicht. Das haben Sie ja auch irgendwann eingesehen, haben Sie ein Mobilangebot gemacht, was insofern mobiler ist, als dass es halt leichtgewichtigeres HTML war.
Genau.
Aber es hatte immer noch keine Möglichkeit, dass ich die Haltestellen, die ich einfach in 99% der Fälle benutze als Ausgangsbahnhof, mir nicht merken kann. Zumindest mit einem Cookie. Es muss ja nicht gleich so ein Account-System sein. Irgendwas.
Cookie würde ja komplett reichen, klar.
Cookie hätte schon mal so ein bisschen gereicht. Aber ich hätte auch mir einen Account gemacht, kein Problem, und mir irgendwie meine Presets da eingestellt, von wo ich normalerweise immer hinfahre und was ich so bevorzuge und womit ich nie fahren würde und so weiter. Kann man doch alles machen, ist ja auch so schwierig nicht. Wie auch immer. Dann kommt jetzt diese iPhone-Applikation und Ihr einziger Kommentar dazu ist äh, Copyright.
Ja, das finde ich, also das finde ich das eigentlich, was man Ihnen vorwerfen kann, ja doch vorwerfen kann, so dieses, das nicht als Chance zu erkennen, sondern dieses, so Angst zu haben. Genau, dass jemand was damit machen könnte und dass jemand irgendwas, also dieses, dieses, naja ok, wahrscheinlich ist es für uns selbstverständlich so dieses, das Web verstehen und das ist für jemand von der BVG wahrscheinlich ein bisschen komplizierter, wenn man nicht so viel im Web unterwegs ist. Ja, aber jetzt ist ja Holter Die Polter tolle Wendung in der Geschichte.
Ja, und es gab jetzt so viel Aufmerksamkeit, dass offensichtlich Leute, die mal ein bisschen abgedacht haben, das Heft der Aktionen gegriffen haben. Ich habe jetzt mit dem Jonas nicht gesprochen, hätte ich ganz gerne noch gemacht. Ich weiß, dass er auf andere öffentliche Nahverkehrsverbünde zugegangen ist und da auch Gespräche geführt hat und dann wohl auch dort nochmal das Gespräch gesucht hat. Oder vielleicht hat man auch das Gespräch mit ihm gesucht. Ich kann das nur erraten. Tatsache ist, dass es wohl ein Gespräch gab und das so verlaufen ist, dass da ein Sinneswechsel hochkam. Dann gab es den zweiten Artikel in der Taz und dort stellt sich das Ganze jetzt so dar. Er kriegt einen Zugriff auf die API. Das heißt, er muss nicht mehr dieses Mobil-Web-Interface scrapen, was er bisher gemacht hat, sondern er kriegt halt richtig einen Datenbankzugang, wie auch immer der...
Muss er wahrscheinlich vorhin NDR unterschreiben, was da ist.
Keine Ahnung, wissen wir nicht, wie auch immer. Er kriegt was.
Ist ja total sinnvoll. Das Gegenteil von dem, was ich erwartet hätte, was ich tue.
Genau. Dann gab es noch diese Zwischengeschichte, ihm fehlten ja noch diese Bushaltestellen. Er kannte zwar die Bushaltestellen, aber wusste nicht, wo sie sind. Also er hatte keine GPS-Koordinaten. Dann hat er ein Programm für das iPhone geschrieben, mit dem man diese GPS-Koordinaten...
Abfangen kann und dann drückt man immer uns.
Genau. Da hat er über Twitter, wer möchte mitmachen, oder ich glaube auch über das Blog. Dann konnte man dann wieder seine iPhone-ID hinschicken. Das habe ich gemacht, habe diese Applikation von ihm bekommen, habe die installiert und bin dann gleich los. Und habe irgendwie... Ich bin irgendwelche Buslinien abgefahren, musste sowieso gerade mal irgendwo hin. Hat ein bisschen länger gedauert, bin halt in der Bushaltestelle kurz gewartet. Mich versichert, um welche es sich hier handelt. Ganz gutes User Interface, aber musste schon auch zweimal gucken. Und dann hat man auf den Fix gewartet. Hier ist die Haltestelle. Und dann konnte man das gleich submitten. Und dann gab es auch noch so einen Rank. Du bist der Number One Submitter und so. Ja, super. Naja, das ging ganz schnell. Ich war ja auch gleich unterwegs, nachdem die Applikation rauskam, was eher Zufall war. Aber das war mir dann schon klar, dass das in Windeseile zum Ergebnis geführt hätte. Die Software hat auch gesagt, wenn für die jeweilige Haltestelle schon fix in der Datenbank ist und so weiter. Ich schätze mal, dass er da so eine Apoxikamination gemacht hat, also umso mehr Values dahin kommen. Leider, und jetzt weiß ich natürlich nicht, wie es bei dem anderen Datensatz ist, bei Bushaltestellen ist es ja so, dass die eine Richtung und die andere Richtung teilweise sehr weit auseinander liegen. Auch bei Straßenbahn-Haltestellen. Das ist natürlich etwas, was man auch noch berücksichtigen sollte. Andererseits geht es natürlich derzeit erstmal nur um dieses Finden, was in der Nähe ist. Und dafür reicht es eigentlich wohl.
Aber hat das OpenStreetMap, hat André nicht Bushaltestellen?
Das ist jetzt auf jeden Fall die Ankündigung, dass sowas kommen soll. Ich weiß nicht, ob OpenStreetMap das drin hat, aber ich denke mal, dass man auf der Basis relativ schnell was finden könnte, weil wenn es das nicht hat, dann kann man schnell dafür sorgen, dass das da drin ist.
Die haben teilweise sogar Briefkästen verzeichnet und sowas. Für sowas wäre das natürlich...
Man sollte sich mehr mit OpenStreetMap auseinandersetzen. Also ich hab seine Ankündigung jetzt so interpretiert, dass bald eine neue Version kommt. Die wird dann eben offensichtlich erstmal alle Bushaltestellen drin haben. Sie wird dieses API, diesen Direktzugriff haben, wahrscheinlich auch den Netzplan wieder benutzen dürfen.
Und hat ein neues Rücken. Und ein neues Rücken. Das ist ja dadurch, dass es von dieser VBB kommt, die sozusagen alle anderen öffentlichen und nicht öffentlichen Verkehrsbetriebe zusammenfasst.
Genau, anschließend BVG.
Die sitzen eins über der BVG und können sagen, wir geben das jetzt einfach mal raus, weil wir müssen uns irgendwie dafür kümmern, dass alle Leute ordentlich fahren können. Haben sozusagen die BVG überstimmt. Und die haben wahrscheinlich alle Rechte an allen Karten und Plänen.
Ach, die haben einfach mit einer anderen Instanz kommuniziert?
Nee, weiß nicht, ob die VBB an den Programmierer zu ist oder eher auf die zugegangen ist. Aber die haben auf jeden Fall die Rechte anscheinend an allen Plänen und Karten und haben die einfach rausgerückt.
Aber das ist doch der Verkehrsverbund Berlin-Brandenburg, das ist doch einfach nur die Organisation, in der dann auch die BVG drin ist, oder?
Eben, aber die BVG ist halt da drin und hat irgendwie...
Keine Ahnung, ob die da irgendwelche Hackordnung haben. Tatsächlich ist jetzt wohl das Agreement mit dem VBB gemacht worden, was ja auch sinnvoll ist, weil das eben von der BVG hinausgeht.
Das heißt also nicht nur die BVG, sondern hat dann auch alle anderen wahrscheinlich.
Wobei vorher das wird auch VBB gewesen sein. Also ich meine, die S-Bahn-Daten hat er auch schon vorher drin gehabt und die sind ja auch nicht BVG.
Ich weiß nicht, wie das organisiert ist. Es war wahrscheinlich schon immer irgendwie VBB, Daten, Material und hat es bloß BVG genannt, weil wir natürlich in Berlin auch so ein bisschen diese Sichtweise haben. Man fährt mit der BVG auch, wenn man S-Bahn fährt, wo es ja eigentlich S-Bahn Berlin respektive Deutsche Bahn ist. Wie auch immer.
Auf jeden Fall haben Sie sich jetzt plötzlich alle lieb. Ich habe bei bestem nicht gerechnet.
Noch kurz zu dieser Applikation. Einen Tag danach gab es dann schon eine Rückruf-Mail von ihm, wo drin stand, Kommando zurück, ich habe jetzt alle Bushaltestellen. Es gibt jemand, der diese Daten bereitgestellt hat. Er hat nicht gesagt, woher das kam. Ich interpretiere das jetzt mal so frei, als dass das schon ein Sinneswandel irgendwo... Also irgendjemand, der diese Daten hatte, dachte sich, es wäre doch mal gut, ihm die zu geben. Keine Ahnung, wie jetzt die Inside-Story dazu ist. Gepaart mit diesem Announcement kann ich nur sagen, gute Entwicklung. Es wird jetzt wirklich spannend werden, zu sehen, was bei dieser Software rauskommt. Es ist auch noch die Rede davon, dass eben Karten eingeblendet werden, dass man eben auch den Weg zur nächsten Haltestelle angezeigt bekommt, dass man quasi so einen Umgebungsplan bekommt. Finde ich super. Mein größtes Anliegen wäre jetzt, dass die BVG, an der Stelle wirklich wohl die BVG, aber ich glaube, die VBB hat es nicht, dass sie auch die Realtime-Daten rauswerfen.
Die ja sowieso an der Bushaltestelle angezeigt wurden.
Genau. Also diese Information, wann kommt der nächste Bus in drei Minuten oder Straßenbahn, basiert auf einer realen GPS-Koordinate, die die Bahnen und Busse selber aussenden. Also jeder Bus, der rumfährt, weiß, wo er ist und sagt der Zentrale, wo er ist. Das heißt, erstens haben die ihre Flotte die ganze Zeit im Blick und zweitens können sie eben auch wirklich genau sagen, wann der nächste Bus kommt, selbst wenn er mal irgendwo im Stau steht. Jetzt wäre es natürlich total klasse, wenn man diese Informationen auch auf so eine iPhone-Applikation live einblenden könnte.
Da hätte man unter Umständen mehr Information, als die Leute direkt am Bahnhof stehen.
Genau. Vor allem, ich meine, was soll ich irgendwo hingehen, wo es im Fahrplan heißt, dass der Bus in fünf Minuten kommt, aber er kommt halt erst in 20 Minuten wegen Bodennebel. Oder weil er ausgefallen ist oder weil Stau ist oder was auch immer. Oder was auch unbedingt wichtig ist, Informationen zu geänderten Umsteigesituationen, Reparaturmaßnahmen, ausgefallene Züge, einfach Bauarbeiten im Allgemeinen. Das ist auf jeden Fall ein Tool, um sich die urbane Welt zu erschließen.
Eigentlich sind wir jetzt ja quasi aus Versehen auf dieses Thema iPhone 22 gekommen, weil da wird ja die Maps-Applikation erweitert werden, um Fußwegmöglichkeiten und was ja in einigen Ländern mit öffentlichen Verkehrsmitteln die Wege geplant werden. Für Deutschland gibt es jetzt noch keinen, der da mit dabei ist. Also keiner der deutschen Verkehrsverbunde hat Google da die Daten gegeben, um so was ausrechnen zu können, wie man von wo nach wo kommt. Aber das wird sich hoffentlich ändern. Es hat sich schon geändert.
Auch da ist mir heute ein Link um die Ohren geflogen. Und zwar steht das direkt bei hcon.de hcon ist die Firma, die für die Deutsche Bahn und auch für die BVG und so weiter, VBB, wie auch immer, diese Fahrplan-Infos macht. Dieses Fahr-Info-Ding, das ist halt diese HFAS-Software, diese Fahrplanauskunft, das ist so der Gold-Standard offensichtlich in Deutschland. Ich weiß nicht, wer das leicht verwendet.
Nicht Gold ist das nicht, aber...
Nein, die Deutsche Bahn verwendet das.
Das ist Standard.
Da ist alles drin.
Gold ist da nichts.
Gold ist es nicht, aber es ist...
Ist benutzbar.
Es ist der Standard. Wie auch immer. Tatsache, hier steht drin, dass Sie diese Daten für Google sozusagen rausgeschmissen haben. Es gibt da ja so ein definiertes XML-basiertes Format, das Google gerne hätte, und dann verleiben die sich das ein und dann haben sie diese Auskunftsinformationen eben auch in Google Maps. Also, sieht ganz gut aus. Mal gucken, ob sich das...
Und die Haferz, die hat auch deutlich mehr als nur deutsche Bahn, sondern die haben ja auch teilweise dann... Haben die BVG-Daten auch mit drin oder nicht?
Du kannst bei der deutschen Bahn richtig auch S-Bahnen und Straßenbahnverbindungen durchsuchen. Ich weiß nicht, ob sie wirklich alle Linien drin haben mit allen Bussen, aber ich glaube schon. Letzten Endes ist das alles eine große Datenbank. Und ich finde das auch gut. Ich meine, öffentliche Verkehrsmittel können nur davon profitieren, dass der Zugang zu dem, wie es funktioniert, so niederschwellig wie möglich ist.
Wenn wir das wollen, das ist ganz großartig, wenn das existiert, die Möglichkeit.
Ja, und der Gedanke, dass das in dem nächsten iPhone-Update schon drin ist und das vielleicht sogar schon zum nächsten Mobile-Max-Podcast... Da sind wir doch ganz...
Da fahren wir nur noch mit der Bahn. Auf dem iPhone, den du schon unten sehen kannst, lohnt es sich jetzt zum Bus zu rennen oder nicht, weil der kommt eh zu spät?
Genau.
Da schafft man als nächstes eine Wecker-Applikation, die einem so weckt, dass man pünktlich zum Bus geht.
Lohnt es sich jetzt noch eine Kippe anzumachen, schon allein da? So endlich ist Murphy sozusagen...
Oh, da schreib ich ein tolles App. Lohnt es sich noch eine Kippe anzumachen? Wir werden das immer sagen, er sagt einfach nur nein.
Ich glaube nicht, dass sie ihm die GPS-Koordinaten der Busse geben würden, weil das ist sicherlich auch so ein kleines Sicherheitsproblem.
So Terror und so.
Nö, so, wenn sie sagen...
Das hast du gesagt.
Das hab ich gesagt.
Gibt jetzt kein Terror, wir haben jetzt Obama.
Bitte, was meinst du, Dennis? Na, man braucht ja nicht Koordinaten, sondern man braucht nur, wenn der Bus normalerweise um acht Uhr kommt. Aber laut iPhone können sie einem die Verspätung schon sagen, dass er erst um acht Uhr zwei kommt. Dann weiß man, alles klar, kann man noch eine Kippe anmachen.
Ja, ich wäre auch schon glücklich, wenn ich einfach sagen könnte, hier um die Ecke die nächste Haltestelle zeigt mir mal genau das an, was da auf dieser Tafel steht. Wo nämlich steht, nächster Zug in zwei Minuten, acht Minuten, 15 Minuten. So, und das zeige ich mir hier einfach an. Das hätte ich auch ganz gerne mal so als Dashboard-Vidget. Und dann so. Und warum nicht? Einfach aufmachen, die API, fertig. Haltestellen, all die hin.
Boah, Texte.
Tafel, Inhalt zurück. Ja, Texte oder vielleicht auch ein bisschen mehr, ein bisschen mehr intrinsischer Logik und so, mit irgendwie Linien-ID oder so. Dass man das auch automatisiert verarbeiten kann. Aber da muss es irgendwie hingehen. Ich hab, aber es gibt auch viele, ich hab viele Links bekommen, da muss ich noch mal ein bisschen sammeln, zu alternativen Fahrplansystemen und so. Da gibt's offensichtlich so einiges. Aber das habe ich jetzt alles nicht im Überblick. Ich denke, das Thema haben wir jetzt ausreichend abgekaut, oder?
Genau, also zum Thema Fahrpläne brauchen wir jetzt erst mal sobald jetzt nichts ganz Dringendes mehr. Hoffentlich. Außer beim nächsten Versionen vom iPhone-Software unten. Aber, da haben wir beim letzten Mal noch ein bisschen rumgerätselt. iPhone aus der Schweiz. Die Schweizer iPhones, die haben ja, wie man ja da frei mit Prepaid-Vertrag kaufen kann, ich weiß nicht wie viel Geld, die hatten ja immer den Nachteil, dass sie einen Netlock drauf hatten. Also, dass man sie nur im jeweiligen Netz verwenden kann.
Die dann auch dadurch viel billiger waren.
Die dadurch, nö, so viel billiger waren die nicht.
Na doch, ein bisschen schon, 300 Euro nur. Anstatt 500.
Nee, im Prepaid-Vertrag. Also, wenn du Prepaid hattest, dann waren die auch relativ teuer. Dann haben die auch so 500 gekostet. Aber, wenn man in der Nähe von der Schweiz wohnt, ist das ja durchaus vielleicht mal ganz interessant gewesen. Aber man hat natürlich immer ein bisschen dieses Problem gehabt, dass man, es gibt ja bisher noch keinen Unlock für das iPhone 3G. Und jetzt habe ich erfahren, dass es da bei Orange in der Schweiz die Möglichkeit gibt, sich das iPhone ganz legal, gegen eine, ich glaube sogar kostenlos, zu sagen, hey, mach mal den Netlock weg. Und dann sagen die alles klar, da war zwei Wochen. Und danach ist dein iPhone nicht mehr genetlockt. Und dann schließt es an an iTunes, und dann wird es aktiviert. Und dann hast du keinen Netblock mehr drauf, und dann kannst du dir eine beliebige SIM-Karte reinstecken. Das heißt, in die Schweiz fahren, zu Orange gehen, sich ein iPhone kaufen, sagen, hey, mach mal den Netlock weg, Karte rausschmeißen.
Gleich beim Kauf.
Das hast du selber ausprobiert.
Das habe ich selber nicht ausprobiert, sondern ich kenne jemand, der das gemacht hat.
Genauso. Der ist da hingefahren, hat gesagt, ich kauf, aber nur, wenn ihr gleich den Netlock rausmacht.
So in etwa. Also ich weiß nicht, ob er es exakt so gemacht hat, aber die machen das anstatt los.
Vielleicht muss man erst mal eine Woche in der Schweiz campen, weil man erst eine Woche später irgendwie dahin darf.
Also es dauert irgendwie zwei Wochen, bis sie es dann freigeschaltet haben, also bis der Netlock dann tatsächlich weg ist. Aber das kannst du auch von Deutschland aus machen, das macht einfach dein iTunes.
Zwei Wochen. Das heißt sozusagen, bei Apple findet das statt.
Das findet bei Apple statt. Gerüchteweise werden diese entsprechenden Belege tatsächlich per Fax rübergeschickt nach Cappatino.
Und die schalten das dann für das Gerät aus.
Das erklärt auch, warum ich, das erklärt mir auch so ein bisschen das Verhalten, was ich heute hatte. Ich hatte nämlich das Problem, dass mein liebes iPhone, das WebKit ist irgendwie völlig zerranzt gewesen. Also egal, was ich da an Caches und Cookies und Verläufen gelöscht habe, nach 90 Sekunden Benutzung bombte mir einfach jeder Webview weg. Also Safari, überall wo ich eine Webseite aus dem Programm heraus geöffnet habe, BUM! Dann bin ich halt hergegangen, hab das im iTunes mal diesen Restore gemacht, wo er ja alles putzt. Die Firmware, jetzt seid ihr die Firmware neu? Weiß ich gar nicht. Die Firmware Restore schon, ja. Und danach ballert er halt das Backup wieder drauf.
Die Firmware auch, wenn es eine neuere gibt, oder irgendwie so. Also beim Update macht auf jeden Fall die Firmware nicht.
Auf jeden Fall, ich beobachte also dieses Telefon, wie es sich permanent irgendwie synchronisierte, neu startete und so weiter. Und zwischendurch kam dann halt auch immer so dieses ich bin ein gelocktes Phone. So und dann wieder irgendwie ein... Nö, nicht sehr. Ich hatte Vertrauen, das wurde auch...
Nicht enttäuscht?
Nee. Und irgendwann musste ich das dann nochmal, also ich musste meine PIN eingeben und dann konnte er irgendwie weitermachen. Also es gab sozusagen einen Zustand in diesem ganzen Restore-Prozess, wo das iTunes erst dann weitermachen konnte, nachdem ich die PIN eingegeben habe.
Der SIM-Karte.
Genau, finde ich auch sehr interessant. Und so weiter und danach war es dann wieder Your Phone is Now Unlocked. Erzählte er mir. Mir ist nicht so hundertprozentig klar, ob sie dann nicht teilweise dann doch nur das Eingeben der PIN meinten oder ob sich das jetzt wirklich auf diesen SIM-Netlock bezog. Unklar. Aber ich hatte schon den Eindruck, dass da irgendwie wild kommuniziert wurde mit der Zentrale.
Mich wundert ja bis heute, dass diese Kommunikation noch von niemandem abgehört worden ist. Ich meine, die müsste auch öfters mal stattfinden.
Wir brauchen eine Online-Durchsuchung bei Apple. Und zwar sollten wir mal im iTunes-Application, im App-Store brauchen wir mal eine Online-Durchsuchung.
Wenn man hier auf dem iPhone seine Developer-Version von seinem Programm installiert, macht er auch jedes Mal eine Connection zu Apple.
Wenn man was macht?
Wenn man mit dem Xcode hier ein Programm draufschiebt, macht er immer kurz eine Connection zu Apple, ob das okay ist. Da dreht sich immer kurz das Rad, dann hab ich mal gesnifft und dann macht es immer zu Apple eine Connection. Muss halt gucken, ob das Profile, was man hat, immer noch valide ist.
Ich verstehe. Ja, ja, so ist das. So, mal kurz hier nochmal einen Blick auf den Chat werfen. Gibt es noch irgendwas Spannendes? Nö.
Dann darfst du jetzt zu deinem Blinkenlides-Projekt privat kommen, oder? Was? Zu dem da.
Ach so.
Kann ich ja schon gehen, oder?
Ich tue so, als ob ich es mir anhören würde. Warte, ich mal mir die Griffe mit den Augen auf.
Was soll denn das heißen? Das ist nicht so uninteressant, oder was?
Nein, nein, nein. Doch, das wird schon spannend.
Wir müssen ja jetzt auch nicht so ein Riesending draus machen, außer weil wir noch andere Themen. Ich wollte noch mal was fragen. Genau. Ja, also erstens, diese Pwnage Tool soll nicht mehr funktionieren auf MacBooks, auf den neuen. Weißt du da was von, Dennis?
Ich hab auch nur gelesen, dass es nicht geht. Ich hab mich da nicht weiter drumherum gekümmert, aber es ist wohl so, dass die Kommunikation mit dem iPhone über so einen speziellen USB-Treiber läuft. Und das haben die wohl, dieses Pwnage Tool nutzt halt auch, spricht direkt mit diesem USB-Kernel-Extension, was auch immer, und der wird sich wahrscheinlich bei den neueren Rechnern ein bisschen geändert haben, und deswegen können die den nicht mehr benutzen. Oder Apple hat wirklich die Lücke zugemacht, aber ehrlich gesagt, glaube ich, das gar nicht so. So richtig verhindert, jetzt haben die ja da noch gar nichts.
Also wie ist denn das, ein iPhone, also das war ja irgendwie ganz merkwürdig. Das war ja nur, wenn man die Firmware, also wo man die Firmware erstellt, oder? Also es war doch so, dass wenn man das Pwnet-Schuhl, wenn man einen anderen Rechner nutzt, um die Firmware zu erstellen, die gehackt wird, dass es dann geht. Aber nicht, wenn man die auf demselben Rechner erstellt.
Nee, ich hab das immer auf meinem eigenen Rechner erstellt. Und ich hab's immer auf meinem Rechner erstellt und mit meinem Rechner aufgespielt. Das ist gar kein Problem.
Ja, ja, ich weiß. Aber soll jetzt bei diesen neuen MacBooks das Problem sein? Nur wenn man die Firmen auf dem eigenen Rechner erstellt, also nur das Pwnit-Stuhl benutzt, wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe. Und nach allem, was Sie verstanden haben...
Ich hab noch nicht gelesen, was Sie da genau meinen, was da nicht mehr gehen soll. Wahrscheinlich geht's erstellen nicht mehr. Dann kann das Pwnit-Stuhl wahrscheinlich nicht mehr prüfen, ob das iPhone irgendwie jetzt im DSM-Modus, DFU-Modus ist oder nicht, was ja bedeutet, dass sie über diese USB-Schnittstelle nicht mehr drankommen. Und da man ja zum Image-Aufspielen gar keinen Pwnit-Stuhl braucht, sondern das macht man ja dann am Ende mit iTunes, das geht dann wahrscheinlich noch, weil das iTunes macht es halt so offiziell, wie es halt geht. Deswegen ist das alles auch gar nicht so. Selbst wenn es wirklich nicht mehr gehen würde und die erst mal Monate brauchen, bis sie da wieder an diesen Treiber rankommen, ist es egal, weil dann erstellt man dieses Image einfach auf irgendeinem anderen älteren Rechner. Also es ist alles easy fixable. Die sollen lieber mal die 2.2 rausbringen. Dann gibt es dann da irgendwelche News. Ist das auch eine Themenkarte?
Ich hab gehört, dass das jetzt in 10 Tagen soweit sein soll, aber ob das eine verlässliche Information ist, weiß ich nicht.
Von dieser griechischen, hast du nicht gesehen, Seite?
Ja, ich glaube. Unklar. Würde mich jetzt auch nicht wundern.
Aber da gibt es auch nicht neuere Infos als vor zwei Wochen, sondern neuen Features oder so, oder?
Es gibt Google Street View.
Das wissen wir alle. Dann gibt es halt die Auto-Correction, die man ein- und ausschalten kann. Dieses Podcast ist wohl reichlich erweitert. Da kommen auch schon Inhalte wohl, haben Sie berichtet.
Man soll dann wohl downloaden können.
Und was gibt es noch?
Beim Lösch eines Programms wird man gefragt, ob man dieses nicht noch bewerten will.
Genau, man wird jetzt beim Ende befragt, ob man bewerten will und man kann alle Updates auf einmal durchführen.
Ich bin gespannt.
So richtig doll viel hört sich das nicht an. Aber okay, es ist auch okay.
Diese Maps-Erweiterung fehlt schon signifikant. Vielleicht schaffen sie es ja sogar, dass die Programme nicht mehr crashen.
Welche?
Na, alle.
Du warst auf dem Tech Talk, oder Tim? Die crashen, weil dein Memory voll ist und dann werden die abgeschossen.
Ja, ich rede aber von Apples Programmen. Ich muss mal schauen. Nachdem ich jetzt den Restore gemacht habe, sieht es erst mal besser aus, irgendwas war braun. Also auf jeden Fall hat sich das Ding selbst zerranzt.
Ich hab immer nur alle paar Wochen, dass ich an meinen Xcode anschließe und der dann sagt, hier, Fehlermeldung 8000003. Du musst dein Telefon mal ausschalten und wieder einschalten, damit es geht. Ich hab ein bisschen rumgefummelt und man muss es wirklich ein- und ausschalten, damit es wieder geht, sonst geht es nicht. Aber das ist auch das einzige Problem. Programme ranzen mir eigentlich nicht ab. Das ist ganz selten bei der Safari.
Ich hab schon die Feststellung gemacht, es bringt hin und wieder mal was. Das sollte eigentlich auch nicht so sein, das iPhone neu zu starten, weil dann sind Programme doch teilweise viel, viel schneller danach. Das kann natürlich bei mir auch noch was mit dem Jailbreak zu tun haben, das will ich jetzt nicht ausschließen. Aber ich hab das Gefühl, dass ich nicht der Einzige bin, dem es so geht, sondern auch Leuten, die kein jailbreaktes Telefon haben.
Aber wenn es so weitergeht mit dem Update-Speed, wann ist diese 2.1 rausgekommen? Wenn es jetzt innerhalb von drei Monaten schon das nächste Update gibt.
Das sind ja wirklich minimale Updates.
Was heißt minimal? Da sind signifikante neue Features drin. Wieso? Was haben wir hier noch gestritten über mein iPhone muss unbedingt Podcasts runterladen können. Jetzt kommt das und jetzt ist es auf einmal minimal. So minimal kann es ja nicht gewesen sein, wenn man vorher so viel Energie drauf verwendet hat, das zu diskutieren. Ich finde auch diesen Street View ein Major Feature. Und ich finde vor allem auch, dass man Weganweisungen bekommt für zu Fuß gehen. Richtig spannend. Weil gerade das ist immer das, was mich total gestört hat. Man will irgendwo hin und will mal sehen, wo man jetzt am besten langlatscht. Und dann kriegt man irgendwie den Hinweis, man muss erstmal in die andere Richtung 300 Meter mit dem Auto fahren. So, was soll das? Als ob es nur Autos gäbe. Und das hätt ich doch ganz gerne. Und wenn jetzt der ÖPNV sozusagen auch noch da reinkommt, dann wird's richtig fancy. Richtig schick. Das ist das, was man will. So ein Navigator in der urbanen Umgebung. Ich hoffe schon die ganze Zeit, dass ich endlich mal in irgendeine deutsche Stadt komme, die ich nicht kenne, um mich damit mal ein bisschen zu lukalisieren.
In Leipzig hat mir das schon mal den Arsch gerettet, dass die Wege so funktionen am iPhone. Das ist ganz toll. Du kannst durch eine Stadt, in der du vorher noch nie warst, hast dieses blöde Ding vor dir.
Erzählt, wie es mir mal den Arsch gerettet hat.
Aber langsam wird die iPhone-Dichte so hoch, dass wenn man so auf der Straße rumrennt mit dem iPhone, Vorsicht, dass die Chance so hoch ist, dass man genau so jemand in die Fresse rennt. Die anderen weiche ich noch aus, weil die haben das alle noch nicht.
Das stimmt.
Aber was bei 2.2 nach wie vor fehlt, ist Push. Das großartig angekündigte. Also nicht Push Mail, sondern dieser Notificationservice. Komplett untergegangen. Und da haben wir ja beim letzten Mal ein bisschen darüber diskutiert.
Da hat doch einer in den Kommentaren zu der Sendung noch mal ein bisschen was gepostet, oder?
Genau.
Das hast du gerade vor dir, dann kannst du ja noch mal kurz rezitieren.
Und zwar hatten wir, warum denn überhaupt so eine offene Datenverbindung, warum die dann überhaupt Strom frisst mehr und ob sie es denn tut. Also ob sie es tut, war ich mir sehr sicher. Und jetzt meinte Mark, dass er seinen Prof befragt hätte. Und das ist wahrscheinlich dann die Idealvariante. Ein Handy lauscht tatsächlich nur auf dem Paging-Channel. Er folgt einem Paging, muss das Handy eine kleine Kontrolldatenverbindung aufbauen und bekommt gesagt, welchen Datenkanal es nun öffnen soll. Über diesen öffneten Kanal fließen dann die tatsächlichen Nutzdaten. Die ganze Apple-Push-Geschichte würde also nur klappen, wenn der entsprechende Netzbetreiber eine Möglichkeit anbietet, damit Apple das Handy pagen kann.
Nur die machen Sie mit Apple in einem Boot stecken und O2 zum Beispiel, zum iPhone nicht, oder wie?
Das wird nicht stattfinden, die machen einfach eine Datenverbindung. Das stimmt schon, dadurch, dass die Datenverbindung besteht, muss dann wahrscheinlich einfach ein Nutzkanal die ganze Zeit offen gehalten werden, was normalerweise eben in dem totalen Idle-Modus nicht der Fall ist. Von daher verbraucht es einfach generell schon mal Strom, unabhängig davon, ob Daten geschickt werden oder nicht.
Oder Sie gehen eben noch diese eine Ebene tiefer und machen mit den Zwingen dann die entsprechenden Provider, oder was heißt zwingen die, fordern die auf, hey, macht mal hier so eine Paging-Verbindung auf. Also lasst uns mal noch eine Portokoll-Ebene tiefer auf GSM-Ebene.
Die haben das auch überall noch nicht so schick implementiert und der Typ hier auf dem Tech Talk meinte auch so, Radio benutzen auf dem iPhone kostet halt Energy und deswegen soll man möglichst sein Zeug immer in einen dicken Burst schicken. Kurz, schnell, viel hintereinander, damit dann auch die das Radio gleich wieder in Sleep Mode schicken können. Und dann soll nichts los sein. Und so ein Push ist ja immer wieder wahrscheinlich... Push ist immer offen eigentlich. Immer offen oder immer wieder zumindest irgendwie nachgucken, ob irgendwie Verbindung noch okay ist oder irgendwie so. Und das saugt wahrscheinlich im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes.
Ja, ich hab noch einen Nachtrag zur Sache mit dem RAM.
Vom iPhone?
Von dem MacBook Pro und dem MacBooks.
Mit dem 6 GB?
Genau. Also der Grund, also Update ist vielleicht ein bisschen übertrieben. Aber was ich so mitbekommen habe, ist das Problem wohl das Timing. Also dieser Chipsatz ist wohl extrem timingsensitiv und es kann sehr wohl sein, dass das RAM mit dem...
Du hast den Heise-Artikel gelesen. Da wo die Nvidia-Chipsatz schon immer ein aggressives Timing hatten. Genau.
Hey, das war die Formulierung. Den hab ich auch gelesen.
Den hab ich, richtig, das ist ein Heise-Artikel. Ich erkenne Heise nicht mehr wieder, seitdem die...
Die neue Optik haben ist ja auch scheiße.
Also ich hab echt Probleme überhaupt zu wissen, dass ich Heise lese. Sie mussten immer so richtig den Titel lesen. Ah, Heise. Richtig. Was genau? Heise. Von daher wissen das sowieso schon wieder alle. Aber das könnte natürlich schon auch der Grund sein, warum es mit diesen 8GB-Chips, die die getestet haben...
Weil die ja eben nicht von Apple kommen, sondern bei Apple bietet ja noch keine 4GB-Chips an oder Module, besser gesagt, sagen wir mal. Sondern das Fremdanbieter. Und die haben das wohl mit den Nvidia-Chipsatz, weil die auch noch so neu ist, noch nicht testen können, sondern nur mit dem älteren Intel-Chipsatz. Und das war wohl die Zusammenfassung, richtig? Und warum aber dann 6GB funktionieren und 8GB aber nicht, ist noch nicht so richtig klar.
Weil das Timing anders ist, wenn beide Steine identisch sind?
Weil sie dann diesen Leuchtenmodus nehmen. Genau.
Das könnte der Grund sein.
Das klingt extrem lohnen.
Dass sie sozusagen auf den 4GB-Stein langsamer zugreifen, als sie es tun würden, wenn beide 4GB sind.
Das sind doch aber eigentlich gute Nachrichten, weil das heißt, wenn erst mal dieses passende RAM mit dem richtigen Timing kommt.
Dann gibt es 8GB.
Dann gibt es 8GB und vielleicht sogar... Achso, nee, kann der ChipSense auch mehr als 8?
Nee, 8.
Äh, ist ja lame. Ich brauch zwei.
Jetzt sind wir schon im... Ja, du brauchst zwölf. Wir sind jetzt in 64-Bit-Zeit, Alter.
Es gibt die Blu-ray-Movies, die nach... ein bisschen runtergerippt werden. Weil die sind ja sonst für 25 GB groß. Der Standard ist jetzt, man rippt die auf 8 GB runter. Und die DVD in Full-Länge, ohne alles weggeschmissen, ist auch so sieben halb.
Und die willst du komplett im RAM haben?
Ja klar, weil Transmission, der muss halt sonst andauernd random rate haben. Ich hab halt noch kein SSD. Wenn ich erst mal SSD hab, dann ist es nicht mehr so schlimm. Aber...
Denn das ist doch Raubkopieren, das ist doch böse.
Ich rede jetzt von Frein-Movies. Von den ganzen freien Blu-ray-Discs.
Ach so, die heimen Videos. Die man auf Blu-ray nicht exzitiert im Blu-ray.
Deine eigenen Blu-rays, die dort zu Hause liegen, hast du aber auf deinem Mac nicht abspielen kannst. Und darum per Current dir die selber zu schickst.
Das letzte World of Warcraft Update, und die benutzen ja auch BitTorrent, seit vier Jahren bald. Also, ich finde, muss man denen schon zu Gute rechnen. Das war 1,6 Gigabyte groß, und das ist demnächst auch riesengroß. Und dann braucht man viel Speicher, damit da nicht so rumgeswoppt wird.
Also, du willst zwölf Gigabyte Speicher haben, damit du acht komplett für BitTorrent einen Bluemail-Film haben kannst und vier noch zum Nebenbei arbeiten.
Klar. Und manchmal lebt man ja auch zwei, drei Sachen gleichzeitig runter.
Weißt du, was das Lustige ist? Die Ansprüche an meine Welt und an deine Welt sind wirklich fundamental unterschiedlich.
Also, RAM kann man nie genug haben. Das ist einfach generell viel RAM für gut.
Ja, aber ich komm mit meinen Vieren im Augenblick relativ gut zurecht.
Weil ich nicht.
Solange ich noch Fessplattenzugriffe habe auf meinem Computer, habe ich zu wenig RAM.
Aber es ist auch bald vorbei. Das SSD geht ja ab wie nix.
Geht es?
Ja, also 2009 ist das Jahr des Flash-Speichers.
Das kann ich mir auch vorstellen.
Das ist einfach so.
Ich hoffe, die können genug bauen.
Klar können die.
Ich hoffe, es gibt noch genug Sand dafür.
Die ziehen dann die Firmen hoch, die werden dieses Zeug rauspusten wie nix. Wahrscheinlich Ende des nächsten Jahres wird so eine Flash-Lawine auf uns losrollen. Kann sein, dass die 2010 schon wieder alle Pleite und Dichtmauerweise zu viele Firmen dafür gedingst haben. Aber jetzt ist erstmal der Umstieg auf Flash angesagt. Also die ganzen Mini- und Kleinstrechner und so, die bauen dann irgendwie nur noch so 64 GB und 128 GB Flash-Module ein. Und die können wir ja auch schon weiter runterfallen.
Ich hoffe, dass dieser Flash-Ramm auch hält.
Klar.
Na die haben ja schon so einen Lifetime.
Der Platten auch.
Ja.
Na ja, der Preis geht ja runter. Das ist ja nicht so das Ding.
Aber der Preis geht auch bei Festplatten runter. Also noch sind die ja nicht auch nur im Ansatz da.
Ja, bei Festplatten geht der Preis aus einem anderen Grund runter. Und zwar bei dem gleichen Grund, warum irgendwie die Fernseher am Ende so billig wurden. Weil keiner mehr haben will.
Was?
Klar.
Keiner will mehr Festplatten haben?
Also ich will schon noch Festplatten haben.
Na demnächst, weil sie werden die Festplatten so richtig abstürzen natürlich, weil dann alle schon eigentlich so in Richtung Flash schielen.
Nee, aber es werden gar nicht alle in so in Richtung Flash schielen.
Du hast einfach die Kapazität noch nicht. Ich meine, du kannst ja irgendwie für 100 Parts der Quetsche, kriegst du jetzt eine Terabyte-Platte für 80 Euro. Und jetzt denk mal, Terabyte in Flash, da sind wir wirklich bei einem sehr, sehr, sehr hohen vierstelligen Betrag.
Schon, aber das ist ja...
Irgendwann, aber ob das nächstes Jahr schon so sein wird, haben wir wieder eine Wette laufen.
Vielleicht wird Flash auch nie werden. Doch, die Nachfolgetechnologie.
Das wäre...
Keine Ahnung.
Die würden wir dann schon ein bisschen im Ansatz irgendwo mal...
Flashram wird schon...
Und jetzt kommen wir nicht mehr Tesafilm.
Das ist radioaktiv.
Röntgenstrahlung. Wo du gerade die Kommentare erwähnst, also dieser Hinweis, wie das da, welchen Einfluss das hat mit dem Push, das war auf jeden Fall ein guter Hinweis. Es gibt hier auch noch eine Frage, wo es ja auch gerade um RAM geht, deswegen schmeiße ich das mal kurz rein. Nee, steht in dem Blog. Hier will sich jemand einen MacBook Pro kaufen.
Ja, super, soll er machen.
Und er fragt, ob sich ein Upgrade von 2-4 GB RAM lohnt. Auf jeden Fall.
Es gibt doch gar keine 2 GB RAM mehr aktuell, oder?
Doch, selten miss ich zwei.
In welchen?
In allen.
Ach, im MacBook?
MacBook Pro.
Nee, die sammeln doch schon mit vier. Der kleine kommt auch wieder nur mit zwei.
Wie der kleine?
MacBook Pro.
Das kleine MacBook Pro hat jetzt zwei Vierer. Mit 2,4 GB.
Jetzt gucken wir das mal. Aber er hat Pro in Klammern geschrieben. Also er überlegt wahrscheinlich.
Nee, aber grundsätzlich, ich weiß nicht, was er genau macht, aber ich hab zwei und das ist einfach nicht mehr schön.
Also ich hab irgendwann mal das Aufrüsten von zwei auf Vieren gemacht, wo ich sehr glücklich war, dass das bei meinem überhaupt ging. Und das hat nochmal wirklich einen ganz gewaltigen Geschwindigkeitsschub gemacht.
Lohnen heißt, dass sich das Geld zu investieren lohnt. Wenn man generell Interesse daran hat, dass der Computer nicht schnell genug sein kann und man möglichst viele Programme gleichzeitig arbeitet, dann hat man halt mit dran.
Ja, aber was kostet diese Aufrüstung?
Naja, sie kostet auf jeden Fall Geld. Das ist aber die billigste Methode, an Performance ranzukommen.
Genau, und auch wirklich gute Performance.
Und die nächstbildliche Methode ist, eine schnellere Platte zu nehmen, das fragt er auch.
Das ist halt noch die Frage, wo er das choppen will, weil Apple ist mit seinen Preisen ja schon immer so ein bisschen...
Beim Ramones hat sich das jetzt gebessert, ne?
Ja, gebessert, aber gebessert heißt noch lange nicht, dass es sich lohnt.
Doch, also es lohnt schon nicht mehr so richtig den Stress.
Zum Beispiel, was ich rausgefunden hab, ich sag jetzt mal meinen Trick, das ist Apple mir bestimmt böse.
Stimmt, das Große hat vier Gigabyte. Aber das Kleine hat zwei.
Ich muss jetzt mal kurz einen kleinen Trick verraten.
Ich glaube, das Große hatte schon immer vier Gigabyte.
Okay, Dennis erzählt mal einen Trick.
Genau, das ist nur ein ganz kleiner Trick. Und ich hab noch kein neues MacBook, verdammt, MacBook Pro. Egal, jedenfalls, wenn man sich das Groß holen will, mit 2,53 GHz, dann kann man ja 50 Euro dazu zahlen, um eine schnellere Platte zu kriegen. Also sie ist gleich groß, aber schneller. Kostet 50 Euro extra. So mein Trick wäre jetzt, man nimmt die 250er-Platte und kriegt den ganzen Rechner für 50 Euro billiger. Macht dann einen 100 Euro Unterschied. Dafür kriegt man ja die 250er. Und von den 100 Euro kaufst du die schnelle 320er. Das heißt, du hast dann zwei Platten, wahrscheinlich noch 30 Euro gespart und hast alles so wie vorher. Plus, dass du halt die 250er-Platte auch noch hast.
Kann man machen.
Kann man denn bei dem 253er dann auch den Arbeitsspeicher weglassen?
Nein, den kannst du nicht weglassen. Das Einzige, was man beim 2,5 Gig, also beim großen 15 Zoller weglassen kann, ist halt, dass du die kleinere Platte nimmst. Und das spart dir 50 Euro. Wobei der Plattenpreis, der Unterschied zu 250er und der 320er im Laden vielleicht 10 Euro ist oder 5 oder so. So und bevor man da irgendwie 50 Euro drauf legt für eine schnellere, sollte man lieber 50 Euro runternehmen vom Preis, sich die 250er geben lassen und mit den 100 gesparten Euro...
Schön essen gehen. Achso, nee, eine Großsitzplatte kaufen.
Die 320er in schnell holen, wenn man denn möchte.
Tja, klingt nach einem Plan.
Da kann man sicherlich noch so das eine oder andere wegoptimieren.
Und ich würde so gebrauchen, dass es eine ganze Menge Händler gibt, die das genau so selber machen und dass den Kunden so weit erreichen und sparen es aber selber kassieren.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, am besten gar nicht direkt bei Apple kaufen, weil bei Apple direkt zahlt man immer ein bisschen mehr.
Nicht alle, aber zum nächsten Thema.
Ich bin auch beim gleichen Thema. Er fragt, lohnt sich eine 4GB, lohnt sich eine 7200 Umdrehungen pro Minute Platte. Mit dem Lohn ist immer eine schwierige Frage.
Speicher würde ich immer Ja sagen. Bei der Platte ändert sich meine Meinung irgendwie alle halbe Jahre. Weil mal brauch ich irgendwie fett schnell Platte und dann denk ich mal, scheiße, jetzt mal eine dicke mit 7200 Umdrehungen und das nächste halbe Jahr denke ich dann, ach man, so eine richtig schöne leise Platte, die muss auch gar nicht so schnell drehen, hält ein Akku ein bisschen länger und ist viel ruhiger und so. Das wär's ja mal. Und das geht immer so hin und her. Es kommt immer drauf an, was man gerade macht. Also da gibt's nicht so die...
Ich nehme immer die leisen Platten, weil mich nichts mehr nervt als Lärm.
Ja, aber das andere halbe Jahr mach ich dann wieder voll viel mit Daten und dann nervt es mich, wenn ich warten muss.
Und dauert's halt. Dann kann man ja ein Eis essen gehen oder so.
Und was ist das Beste aus beiden? SSD in dem Fall tatsächlich.
Wobei es da auch Unterschiede gibt. Die SSD, die Apple einbaut, sind wohl nicht so die fixesten. Es gibt von Intel SSD-Module.
Die kosten aber auch wirklich, und die machen 250 MB. Sustain.
Ja, es gibt schöne Videos auf YouTube, wie die in ein neues MacBook Pro eingebaut sind.
War doch bei Barefoot oder irgendeinem Typ hat das doch gemacht. Und man meinte es ist amazing.
Dann Fotoshops und bang.
Programm starten, feinde Anzeige. 32 GB für 500 Dollar oder so.
So teuer sind sie nicht mehr.
Ich hab mal gelesen, dass die gar nicht so teuer sind.
Das war die Server-Version. Kann sein, dass die noch mal mit extra lange hält. Es gab auch noch eine Nicht-Server.
Also ich glaube so 128 GB oder 256 GB müssten so um die 600, 700 Euro sein.
Also wenn man die Cola hat und wirklich ein leises Laptop fürs Bett haben will oder irgendwie so, dann kann man sich das mal erlauben.
Ich hab da jetzt auch gerade keinen passenden Link, dem ich hinterher klicken könnte.
Aber die Frage, die ja dann auch, lohnt sich das Upgrade von 2,4 GHz auf 2,53 GHz?
Das ist ja die gleiche Geschichte.
Das ist ja die große Version mit dem vielen Speicher drin.
Also ich würde sagen, wenn das Geld locker sitzt, dann fragt er mich.
Also ich würde sagen, nein.
Na ja, wieso lohnen? Klar lohnt sich das. Also wenn du einen Rechner kaufst mit mehr Prozessor-Power, mit mehr RAM für deine Grafikkarte, mit einer schnelleren Platte und mehr RAM, dann ist der Computer schneller als vorher. Aber ob diese 10%, die du da maximal rausholen kannst, und ich würde sagen, 10% ist hier vielleicht noch zu holen, für alle Sachen kombiniert. Platte, mehr RAM und ein bisschen Prozessor, da kannst du dann vielleicht so 10% rausholen, im Idealfall. Aber im Normalfall...
450 Euro wert ist...
Ich denke, wenn man weiß, unter welcher Last der eigenen Computer steht, dann könnte man sowas einfach problemlos machen. Aber wenn man eigentlich sich unsicher ist, dann sollte man es sein lassen. Weil dann ist der Rechner immer noch schnell genug.
Und wahrscheinlich sogar, wenn jemand fragt, ob sich's lohnt, dann lohnt sich's wahrscheinlich nicht, weil einer, der so ein Hardcore-User ist, der fragt dich, der nimmt immer...
Ich hab mal den relativ interessanten Tipp gehört, ich weiß nicht, ob das überhaupt noch zutrifft, könnte man mal nachrechnen, dass es sich durchaus lohnt, einmal im Jahr das zweitbeste Modell zu kaufen, anstatt alle zwei Jahre das Beste. Und das dann wieder zu verkaufen, weil das teuerste Modell, da zahlts ja nochmal, gerade bei Apple, nochmal ein gewissen Premium drauf dafür, dass du das beste Modell hast. Und das dementsprechend und dann halbes Jahr später...
Ah, der Wiederverkaufswert ist aber bei beiden später gar nicht mehr so doll unterschiedlich, meinste.
Genau, und dafür sollte man sich dann lieber, und nach einem Jahr gibt es sowieso das Modell, was dann eben dreimal so schnell ist, oder eben... Nein, nicht dreimal so schnell, aber deutlich schneller ist auch als das beste Modell von eben gerade, was ja eigentlich nur so eine kleine 10% oder so was in dem Dreh ist. Und dass man dann auch lieber sagen soll, verkopp ich das doch nach einem Jahr wieder, hab...
Ist auf jeden Fall zu empfehlen, weil der Wiederverkaufspreis von Macs ist ja immer noch erstaunlich hoch. Gerade nach einem Jahr, ich würde sagen, nach einem Jahr hat das Gerät fast, also wenn du keine Schäden dran hast und wenn du nicht gerade mitten in so eine Transition PowerPC, Intel oder so eingekauft hast.
Wo jetzt mit dem neuen Gehäuse?
Ja, wobei das glaube ich zum Beispiel spielt nicht so eine große Rolle. Das mag auch ein bisschen ausschlaggebend, aber es gibt viele Leute, die einfach mit dem alten MacBook Pro total zufrieden sind. Weil das hat auch eine Tastatur, das hat auch einen Bildschirm und die sind glücklich, wenn sie so einen Teil bekommen, weil von der Performance zum Beispiel, wenn man jetzt mal von der Grafik absieht, ist es noch absolut kompetitiv. Das ist jetzt nicht so wie PowerPC, Intel, dass das Ding auf einmal Faktor 2 oder 3 hinlegt. Von daher wirst du für so ein Gerät, was ein Jahr alt ist, also MacBook Pro oder auch MacBook, was ja auch noch den großen Vorteil hat, dass es noch Firewire hat, da wird es jetzt auch noch viele Leute geben, die daran Interesse haben. Gut, noch gibt es ja das kleine Modell auch noch zu kaufen, trotzdem. Und wenn man nach einem Jahr verkauft und das Gerät hat keine Schäden, dann gibt man wahrscheinlich sehr wenig Geld aus. Und die Differenz zum neuen Modell, wenn man das dann mal auf ein Jahr umschlägt, dann hat man vielleicht eine Miete von 50 Euro im Monat. Wenn überhaupt. Wenn es nicht sogar noch viel weniger ist.
Ich wollte mal meinen iBook verkaufen, hab geguckt, was die bei anderthalb Jahre alt, was die bei Ebay damals so gebracht haben. Das war komplett irre. Ich hätte es teurer verkaufen können, theoretisch, als ich es gekauft habe damals. Hab ich im Endeffekt nicht gemacht. Ich wollte für einen Kumpel einen Preis finden und hab dann gesagt, ey, den Preis kann ich dir nicht verkaufen. Das wäre Betrug an dir. Aber da haben die Leute bei 500, da gab es schon die übernächste Generation, immer noch mehr ausgegeben, als ich da neubefürbezahlt habe. Das war Wahnsinn.
Also der Durchschnitt in meinem Bekanntenkreis, ich kenn jetzt drei Leute mit einem neuen MacBook Pro. Davon haben zwei irgendwie die rechts unten Version genommen mit 2,8 Gigahertz und eine Person das mit 2,53 Gigahertz. Also niemand hat das kleine genommen. Und zwei sogar nochmal die CPU für 300 Euro extra aufgerüstet.
Also ich hätte das kleine genommen. Also ich würde das kleine nehmen, wenn ich eins kaufen würde.
Ich muss jetzt auch das dicke mit 28.
Naja sonst stehst du da und hast noch Akku. So hast du da garantie keinen mehr.
Ich bin ja noch viel raffinierter, weil ich sag euch jetzt schon was passieren wird. Und da können wir von mir aus mal um eine Mate wetten. Also eine. Also von mir aus noch jeweils. Ich bin mal mutig heute. Ich glaube, dass das nächste Update, was so in einem halben Jahr kommt, weil es war ja immer so circa, diese Mini-Update, die Sie jetzt nachschieben vom MacBook Pro, dass das nächste eine höhere Auflösung hat.
Warum?
Na, weil Apple natürlich nicht blöd ist und die ganzen coolen Sachen in einen Generationswechsel stecken. Sondern die müssen ja beim nächsten Mal auch wieder einen Grund haben, warum sie sagen, warum das nächste toller ist als das letzte. Also machen sie das größere Display, was eigentlich mal wirklich fällig gewesen wäre, weil andere sind bei 1920 inzwischen bei 15 Zoll.
Als Option.
Ja, von mir aus auch so. Jedenfalls kommt das erst beim nächsten Update. Oder? Ja, glaube ich. Weil beim 17 Zoll haben sie es auch gemacht und eigentlich wär es beim 15 Zoll auch mal fertig. Und wirklich, diese IBM-Teile, die haben auf 15 Zoll, haben die 1920 Pixel.
Aber da muss die Schrift bei mir in meinen BBL größer, dann komm ich nicht mehr klar.
Dann machst du halt die Schrift größer. Oder dann muss man halt wirklich langsam diese...
Was ist die Auflösung derzeit?
1440. 1440.
1440. Und das 17 Zoll in der Kleinen hat 1680.
Genau, man kann es in der Großen für 1920 kaufen.
Und du meinst?
Das hier auch mit 1680, anstatt 1440.
Das sind die 17 Zoll Mini Auflösungen.
Genau.
Hier als...
Ja, als Große.
Ja, ich weiß nicht, ob es diese Displays gibt, aber wenn es gibt, find ich das auch mal eine coole Option.
Das gibt 1920 auf 15 Zoll.
Aber 1920 auf 15 Zoll, das wird dabei im Bild nicht einbauen.
Da krieg ich nämlich genau dieser Effekt zu zahlen.
Das ist schon richtig. Aber so 1680 ist gerade Standard.
Das wäre das selbe Verhältnis wie die hohe Auflösung auf dem 17 Zoll. Ich kann da nicht gegenwetten. Also ich weiß nicht, ob das jetzt schon in der nächsten Version kommt.
In einem halben Jahr.
Keine Ahnung. Ich denke vor allem, dass sie dann erst mal in die nächste Prozessor-Generation reinkaufen.
Die wird eher mal fällig.
Übrigens sollte man nicht unterschätzen, die 2,4 Gigahertz-Version von Macbook Pro hat auch nur 3 MB Second-Level-Cache und die 2,5-3er-Version hat ja 6 MB Second-Level-Cache. Und das ist ja heute entscheidend, weil CPU kommt ja megahertz-mäßig oder gigahertz-mäßig, passiert da eigentlich auch schon nicht mehr so viel. Das sind ja andere Sachen entscheidend.
Hat er weniger Second-Level-Cache als meins gerade?
Ist ja auch das Kleine. Du hast ja ein großes von dem Alten.
Nee, ich hab ein kleines. Ja, mit 2,2 Gigahertz und 4 MB Second-Level-Cache.
Kannste mal sehen. Ich hab auch vier. Aber meins ist ein bisschen älter als deins. Und ich hab das große.
Tja, ich bin, wenn überhaupt, ein Kunde fürs MacBook. Dann aber für das große MacBook. Weil wenn schon Upgrade, dann auch wieder mal beleuchtete Tastatur. Das fand ich so scheiße nicht damals, als ich es noch hatte.
Ich frag mich schon Leute, ob man sich nicht das kleine kaufen kann und dann sich eine Beleuchtetastatur extra bestellen kann. Dann hab ich ihn ausgelacht.
Soweit ich weiß, geht das nicht.
Ja, Apple auch schon blöd, oder?
Also ich für meine Zeit...
Plötzlich tausende Bestellungen, eine Beleuchtetastatur, dann kommt die so, hä, und gehen die dann so aus kaputt?
Also ich hab mich beim MacBook Pro damals sehr drauf gefreut auf diese Beleuchtetastatur, und ich benutze sie exakt nie. Also das ist...
Ehrlich gesagt benutze ich es auch nicht so oft, aber manchmal ist es schon praktisch.
Also ich hab sie nicht nie benutzt. Es gab leider nur komische Situationen, wo sie sehr schwierig zu benutzen waren. So im Twilight konnte sich die Tastatur manchmal nicht so richtig dafür entschließen.
Genau, also die Automatik...
Ob sie jetzt ansehen soll oder nicht.
Das Problem ist die Software. Die suckt einfach. Wenn ich im Lock-In-Bildschirm bin, also nicht im Lock-In, sondern im Screensaver mit, wo ich meine Credentials eingeben muss, mein Passwort, dann kann ich nicht, wenn es alles dunkel ist und ich muss mein Passwort eingeben, dann kann ich nicht F8 drücken, weil man darf ja nichts anderes machen, außer sein Passwort einzugeben, dann kriege ich mein Display nicht beleuchtet. Und genau da bräuchte ich es.
Das ist wirklich bekloppt.
Weil danach ist mein Bildschirm ja hell, weil ich habe einen schwarzen Screensaver, da ist nichts beleuchtet.
Man lockt sich einen, danach geht die Tastatur an. Das ist so bekloppt, da geht es wirklich überhaupt nicht mehr.
Muss es vorher sein. Und vor allem muss er merken, aha, der tippt jetzt, einfach mal einschalten. Das ist ja ganz egal.
Hast du schon mal einen Bug gefällt?
Nö.
Das ist ein Bug, den man feilen sollte.
Kann sein.
Ich hab Bugs gefällt, die sind fix worden.
Vielleicht mal an Steve schreiben.
Oder so.
Wie schlecht ist das denn?
Der beschimpft dich dann.
Ist ja okay, ob der fixt es dann auch.
Tja, ich hatte hier noch so eine Gesprächsthemenkarte. Ah ja, genau, wo wir noch so ein bisschen in die Glaskugel gucken. Ihr habt mitbekommen, dass der Chef von AT&T angekündigt hätte, dass das iPhone als Modem eingesetzt werden soll. Zeit wird's. Wie? Bluetooth oder WLAN?
WLAN, ist mir egal. Hauptsache es geht.
Aber was denkst du, was sie tun werden? Jetzt kommt meine Chance, die Marze gleich wieder zurückzugewinnen, die ich jetzt nicht aufs Bild gesetzt habe.
Ich würde behaupten... Er muss ja dann DSM machen, um sich sein Zeug zu holen. Gleichzeitig muss er auf der anderen Seite auch noch mal funken. Erstmal saugt schon das Telefon ganz schön leer. Sie werden das nehmen, was weniger Strom verbraucht. Da könnte ich mir gut vorstellen, dass Bluetooth da stromverbrauchsmäßig besser ist.
Ich tippe so stiefmütterlich, wie Sie bisher Bluetooth behandelt haben, werden Sie es auch weiterhin tun. Ich tippe eher auf WLAN oder über USB.
USB? Nee, auf keinen Fall.
Ranstecken, als Modem nutzen.
Nee, das ist ja, nee.
Dann wird es nicht so schnell leer sein.
Du willst nicht im Zug sitzen mit deinem Rechner und dann hängt da so ein Kabel mit Dings dran. Nee, das ist ja, nee.
Das glaube ich nicht. Ich tippe auf Bluetooth. Erstens, WLAN hieß ja, das Telefon müsste in den Access-Point-Modus gehen.
Haben Sie die Software für DAW? Wäre nicht so das Problem?
Ja, aber dann würden Sie ja sozusagen, das wäre dann schon zu cool, weil dann könnte man ein Telefon in die Mitte des Raums legen und zehn Laptops könnten da drüber surfen. Ich glaube, das ist jetzt nicht...
Mit der Bluetooth mache ich das auch so. Bluetooth zu meinem Rechner und mein Rechner macht die Station.
Okay, aber das ist eine andere Geschichte. Aber Bluetooth hat auch explizit diesen Pan-Modus, der wirklich genau dafür gedacht ist, dass sich eben so ein Bluetooth-Ding als Interface auf dem Mac anmeldet. Das funktioniert ja auch wunderbar. Und ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass sie das über Bluetooth pan machen.
Das ist der modernste Shit.
Ja, das ist... The way to go Bluetooth ist für Personal Area Networks für ein Gerät in deiner Nähe gedacht. Und sie haben das da auch drin. Warum sollten sie es nicht benutzen? Und dann kannst du halt deinen Mac relativ einfach über dein iPhone da halt einwählen. Keine Ahnung, vielleicht sind sie auch cool und machen das mit so einem Access Point. Ich glaub's bloß nicht.
Aber es kostet wirklich reichlich mehr Strom als Bluetooth, oder? WLAN mehr als Bluetooth. Bluetooth war doch schon wirklich darauf designt, auch möglichst wenig Strom zu verbrauchen. Das war bei WLAN eigentlich nie der Fall. Sondern die haben irgendwie immer nur mehr, mehr, mehr, schneller, schneller, schneller. Und es kann ja auch G das Telefon. Und man braucht kein G, um irgendwie das UMTS zu übertragen.
Ja, also ich denke, Bluetooth reicht aus. Sie haben es drin. Es hat alle Voraussetzungen. Sie haben auf der Mac-Seite software-mäßig auch schon alles installiert. Dieser Panth-Support. Und das funktioniert auch so, wie man es dann haben will. Dann ist das iPhone einfach ein Network-Interface, was man anwählt und dann hat man darüber ein Netz. Und das hätte man über WLAN auch gar keine Frage.
Also ich halte dagegen. Ich behaupte, dass irgendjemand es liefert. Bei Apple Bluetooth überhaupt nicht leiden kann, weil so schlecht wie das bisher behandelt worden ist, auf dem iPhone. Ich glaube nicht, dass sich daran noch was bessern soll.
So schlecht?
Nee, du kannst Bluetooth...
Auf dem iPhone meint er.
Auf dem iPhone. Du kannst es benutzen für exakt eine Aufgabe und zwar um dein Headset anzuschließen. Du kannst keine Musik darüber übertragen. Du kannst keinen Datenverkehr herstellen. Du kannst es nicht mit dem Rechner synchronisieren. Du kannst nichts machen. Das stimmt. Und du kannst dich nicht mal... Ich glaube, es gibt nicht mal eine Möglichkeit, das Telefon Discoverable-Modus zu versetzen.
Ja, aber wie schön wäre es, wenn Sie das dann einfach alles mal einschalten, diese Funktionalität, dass du Netz und Sünden...
Ich habe so ein bisschen das Gefühl, dass Sie es so richtig gar nicht vorhaben, sondern eher darauf warten, dass WLAN die Bluetooth ablösen wird. Also es gibt ja so erste Ansätze, WLAN genau dieses Stromspanle beizubringen.
Das ist auch ein Security-Argument. Bei WLAN hast du halt kein Pairing. Also das Bluetooth hat ja auch so ein gewisses Security-Modell.
Ja, aber das könnte man alles bei WLAN ja nachrüsten. Ich glaube, daraus wird es...
Erstmal auf deinem iPhone musst du das Modus versetzen, dann musst du ein Passwort vergeben, dann muss das Telefon, damit das sicher ist, muss es irgendwie WPA sprechen.
Vielleicht stellen sie diese erste Verbindung ja sogar per Bluetooth her oder machen das eben über USB mit, du schließt es in dein... Das wird so simpel sein. Die machen das so, du schließt das Ding dran.
Du kannst auf deinem Mac keinen Access-Point aufmachen mit einem WPA-Sponsor. Du kannst nur WEP machen.
Du machst einmal die Verbindung über iTunes, dabei quatschen die sich ab, sagt dein Mac, alles klar, du bist mein iPhone und ab da weiß der über WLAN mit wem er zu kommunizieren hat, nämlich mit dem da. Und dann muss man da gar nichts einstellen.
Tja, aber über WLAN musst du halt auch erstmal irgendwie eine Authentifizierung hinkriegen.
Ja klar, aber das machen sie über iTunes. Vorher. Da wird dann eben der Schlüssel ausgetauscht.
Wir wissen es nicht.
Bei Bluetooth natürlich dafür. Da muss ich wieder lassen.
Abschluss, du sagst WLAN, ich sag Bluetooth und du sagst...
Also was mich jetzt gerade mal so ein bisschen in Zweifel bringt, ist, Bluetooth kann man relativ entspannt im Hintergrund laufen lassen, ohne dass es extrem viel Strom schluckt. Wohingegen...
Genau, das haben wir denn ja schon gesagt.
Der Access-Point in Benutzung ist wahrscheinlich gar nicht... Also es ist auch nochmal ein Unterschied, aber einfach der Access-Point die ganze Zeit im Hintergrund laufen müsste, damit man es vom Mac möglichst einfach nutzen kann. Das... Okay, da gebe ich dir recht. Na gut, wir werden es sehen.
Wir werden es sehen. Ja, dann fällt mir nur noch ein, dass ich irgendwo... Mr. Gruber meinte, dass die iPhone-Kopfhörer jetzt aus Teflon sind und nicht mehr aus Pflaster, nicht mehr aus PVC.
Bei den neuen jetzt oder wie?
Mit einem Worten, da rutscht der Ohrschmalz ab, oder was?
Die vertengeln sich nicht mehr so leicht. Ach, die Kabel! PFC ist doch böse und die sind doch jetzt green. Und da darf man nicht so viel Zeug ausliefern lassen.
Das wäre glaubt ein Grund, mir noch mal demnächst mal ein neuer iPhone-Kopfhörer zu kaufen. Also nicht wegen den Greens.
Benutzt du die denn?
Da sind meine iPhone-Kopfhörer. Ich nutze die ständig.
Ich hab die noch nie benutzt.
Ich hör da immer Musik drüber und so.
Also für meine Ohren sind diese Dinger nix. Mir tut das weh, wenn ich die da reinstecke.
Also ich hatte das auch so. Ich hatte so ganz schicke...
Also mich wundert, dass so viele Leute damit klarkommen. Bei mir verkantet sich das, ich hab irgendwie krumme Ohren.
Nee, also ich bin mit Kopfhörern eigentlich relativ glücklich.
Wir haben ja schon festgestellt, du hörst nicht so gut.
Ich höre nicht so gut, aber das hat ja nichts damit zu tun, wie gut die Dinger physikalisch in meinem Ohr hängen bleiben. Ich höre viel, aber ich mag Bügel-Kopfhörer.
Vielleicht ist dein Ohrkanal irgendwie schräg und deswegen...
Mein Ohrkanal?
Ja, was auch immer.
Ich hab einen schrägen Podcast-Kanal.
Man hat auch seine Ohren wie beim Elefanten so Riesenlappen. Also nicht so Riesen, aber so, weil die ja mehr oder weniger so trichter sind, damit man gut hört, damit es schön eingefangen wird.
Ich hab mir diese Sony-Kopfhörer gekauft.
In ihr?
Leider nicht so ganz. Nee, nee. Ich mag nicht in ihr. Ich will nicht in mein Ohr was reinstecken. Ich möchte, dass es so da drüber schwebt. Mit einem kleinen Bügel, den du einfach übers Ohr machst. Das hat auch den Vorteil, du kannst halt einen abnehmen und den anderen noch dranlassen. Sehr praktisch, wenn man irgendwie mal mit seiner Außenwelt kommunizieren muss, aber trotzdem folgen möchte, was passiert, egal ob man gerade telefoniert oder irgendwas hört. Und ich hab mir solche genommen, die halt noch einen Knopf haben, sodass du das Kabel in den Kopfhörermuscheln versenken kannst.
Die hatten wir doch sogar schon mal hier im Podcast dabei. Wo ich die so extrem gelobt hab.
Ich weiß gerade nicht, wo sie liegen. Hab ich dir das alles schon mal erzählt? Ich weiß es nicht. Und dann halt auch dieses Adapter-Teil von Griffin, was mir daraus ein Headset macht.
Mit Mikro, genau.
Aber ich hab so ein bisschen Wackelkontakte und die Dinger sind leider auch nicht... Die Kabel sind immer viel zu schnell kaputt. Deswegen vertengeln die sich wieder, wenn sie draußen sind. Also ich hab das Optimale noch nicht gefunden. Ja, die sind nicht besonders robust. Das ist das Problem. Ich hoffe, dass dieses neue Headset endlich rauskommt. Von Apple, was sie angekündigt haben mit Volume Control. Und dass es dann auch entsprechendes Party-Angebote gibt. Weil das ist eigentlich das, was man unbedingt noch braucht. Wie?
Wo haben die ein neues Headset angekündigt?
Als letzten iPhone-Update gemacht.
Ach, das was du da meint, was auch gleich Mikro drin hat und so.
Mikrofon haben sie ja jetzt schon drin.
Mikro mit Lautstärke, irgendwas war da.
Lautstärke.
Zwei Tasten mehr.
Zwei Tasten mehr. Und das ist eigentlich das Einzige, warum man überhaupt sein iPhone in der Tasche noch bedienen möchte wegen der Lautstärke.
Aber das war damals nur angekündigt, nach wie vor. Ich weiß nicht, ob sich das mittlerweile geändert hat für iPod Touch und iPod.
Naja, das ist unklar. Gibt es die Dinger denn jetzt mittlerweile schon?
Ich glaube, die gibt es immer noch nicht.
Ich glaube auch, die gibt es immer noch nicht. Hab ich noch nicht gehört. Sie haben sich nicht dazu geäußert, ob das auf dem iPhone dann auch funktioniert. Ich meine, mich würde es nicht wundern, wenn das mit der Firmware 2.2 dann kommt. Ich meine, was sollte sie davon abhalten? Das ist eh nur eine Codierung auf dem Signal.
Ah, ich hab hier gerade im FSCK-Log einen Artikel genau zu dem Thema offen. Auch den verzögerten Kopfhörer mit Mikro- und Fernsteuerung dürften noch im November ausgeliefert werden. Laut Spezifikation spielen diese nur mit den neuen iPod Classic, iPod 9 oder der vierten Generation und den iPod Touch der zweiten Generation zusammen. Ob letztendlich auch das iPhone diese mit iPhone OS 2.2 inklusive Fernbedienungsmöglichkeiten nutzen kann, bleibt vorerst offen. Also noch funktioniert das offensichtlich nicht. Was mich sehr gewundert hat, ich dachte, also...
Wie ich schon sagte, es ist ein Software-Update erforderlich. Denkt doch mal nach.
Das kam schon zu 2.1. Denn iPod Touch der zweiten Generation...
Das kam noch gar nichts, es gibt dieses Teil nicht.
Es gibt das noch nicht, aber schon die ganze Zeit...
Warum sollten Sie Software releasen für etwas, was noch gar nicht zu kaufen ist?
Warum sagen Sie dann, den wird's geben für den neuen iPod Touch, aber nicht fürs iPhone?
Weil Sie gerade das neue iPod Touch vorgestellt haben und allen Leuten klar machen wollen, wie cool das neue iPod Touch ist?
Aber Sie haben auch kurze Zeit vorher das neue iPhone 3G vorgestellt. Ich bin mal gespannt. Wir werden's sehen. Das ist ja jetzt, um zu diskutieren.
Wie auch immer. Ich sehe keinen zwingenden Grund, weil es ist ja kein eigener Stecker dafür nötig.
Ich sehe den Grund auch nicht.
Es ist einfach nur der normale Mikrofoneingang und wenn du diese Tasten drückst, hast du irgendwelche hohen Frequenzen, die da drauf generiert werden und das ist der Input. Genauso wie das mit dem Button jetzt auch funktioniert.
Mir ist das ja auch, also ich gehe ja auch davon aus, dass ein Software-Applet reichen dürfte, aber sie behalten sich zu dem Thema eben noch relativ.
Wo wir beim wetten sind, ich sag die 2.2-Firmware wird dieses Feature fürs iPhone einführen und dann sind wir alle glücklich. Was ich mich aber eigentlich frage ist, man kann die Dinger ja auch bei den neuen Mac-Box betreiben. Das heißt, es gibt jetzt noch einen weiteren Audio-Eingang im Headphone-Output. Und ich weiß nicht, was das für ein Level ist, was das für ein Mikrofon ist, was das für ein Eingang ist. Das ist offensichtlich kein Line-In, weil da kann ja in dieser iPhone-Strippe, in diesem iPhone-Headset, da ist ja kein Verstärker drin. Dieses Mikrofon wird einen Mikrofon-Pegel liefern. Bloß sie sagen halt nichts darüber, was für ein Pegel das ist. Also es gibt ja im Prinzip drei verschiedene Betriebsmodi für so ein Mikrofon an Geräten. Entweder du hast da deinen Verstärker drin und du kannst einen richtigen Line-In-Pegel liefern. Wenn du eine Batterie in so ein Mikrofon reinlegst, sowas gibt es. Du kannst Kondensatormikrofone kaufen, Batterie rein. Dann liefern die halt schon ein verstärktes...
Ein Line-In-Pegel, ob es auch so ein Wert irgendwie?
Keine Ahnung, wie das spezifiziert ist. Auf jeden Fall mit mehr Wurm. Also das, was halt hier aus deinem Computer auch rauskommt. Oder was halt jetzt hier gerade den Podcast aufnimmt zum Beispiel. Das ist so ein Line-In-Pegel. Ein Mikrofon, so ein unverstärktes Teil, liefert halt einen viel niedrigeren. Deswegen brauchst du ja auch immer so einen Vorverstärker, wie wir das hier auch haben. Unsere Mikrofone sind ja auch erstmal einen Vorverstärker angeschlossen. Damit das überhaupt erstmal auf so ein Mixer-Level kommt. Und ich frage mich jetzt, was dieser zusätzliche Port bei den MacBooks so kann. Ob der sowohl Mikro als auch Line kann, wie der normale Eingang oder eben nur Mikro und was das heißt. Dann gibt es noch die Möglichkeit, einen Plug-In-Power zu liefern, dass da so ein 5-Volt-Pegel drauf anliegt, mit dem das Mikrofon arbeiten kann, um sich selber zu verstärken. Diese ganzen UKM Soundman Mikrofone, diese Kunstkopfdinger, die funktionieren zum Beispiel so. Das wäre alles ganz hilfreich. Und dann wäre natürlich auch super, wenn diese Volume-Control funktioniert. Ich glaube, haben Sie erst nicht sogar gesagt, dass das geht? Dass man mit diesen Volume-Controls auch die Lautstärke im iTunes steuern kann? Echt was?
Nee, nee, das kann ja noch niemand überprüfen, weil...
Glaskugel.
Das kann ja noch niemand überprüfen, weil noch niemand die Kopfhörer hatte.
Bitte?
Hat ja noch niemand die neuen Kopfhörer. Dann kann man es ja niemand überprüfen, ob man damit die Lautstärke regeln kann.
Genau, es ist unklar. Also wir wissen es alles nicht. Hier im Chat wird klug gesagt, Minus zehn dBV ist Leinpegel. Dezibel Volt. Mist man das? Keine Ahnung, wenn es um Strom geht, bin ich eine Null. Wie auch immer. Ich habe jetzt meine Themen durch hier, Jungs. Außerdem einen.
Vom blauen Wunder. Hast du das schon Namen?
Das heißt Podcast Studio.
Ich dachte, du gibst mir jetzt irgendwie so einen Knuffelnamen.
Knuffelnamen, mal gucken. So gut kennen wir uns ja noch nicht. Das ist ja hier alles noch ganz frisch.
Du meinst, du wartest noch bis der Benennung.
Man soll dem Tag sich vor dem Abend loben.
Aber geiles Blinkenleits, oder?
Total.
Ihr zuppt und zippelt die ganze Zeit, finde ich super.
Und alle gleichzeitig und so weiter. Das ist schon ganz schick. Jetzt muss man nur gucken, ob die Sendung ordentlich rausfällt und du nicht wieder irgendwas verkackt hast.
Also sag mal...
Naja, das ist ja analog. Ich hab mit Digital-Audio eine Menge Probleme gehabt. Ich meine, mein Recorder läuft. Ich hab hier einen Pegel, wenn ich spreche. Also geh ich davon aus, dass da auch was kommt.
Eigentlich würde man doch so, hier diese Musiker und so, die nehmen doch zum Beispiel von jedem Musiker oder jedes Instrument, wird doch eine eigene Spur aufgenommen. Das wird dann später zusammen gemixt. Da ist zum Beispiel einer, zum Beispiel Tim, das ist ja auch ein Instrument, der ist dann zu laut, dann regelt man den ein bisschen runter. Das kannst du nicht machen, weil du nimmst uns alle drei schon zusammengeführt auf, richtig?
Richtig. Als Stereo-Signal.
Also das nicht hier so in ein Garage-Dingens-Band, irgendwie so drei Spuren, wo du dann irgendwie alles machst, sondern du nimmst jetzt schon genau eine Spur auf.
Richtig.
Das will ich aber. Das will ich auch machen. Dafür brauch ich allerdings noch ein weiteres Modul. Ich hab jetzt erstmal...
Wie, das willst du aber? Du willst drei Spuren aufnehmen irgendwann?
Das lässt sich ja über ein entsprechendes Soundmodul machen.
Ich hab das früher ja auch gemacht. Ich hab damit angefangen.
Sollten wir vielleicht überhaupt erzählen, worum es geht? Tim hat hier sein Podcast-Studio ersetzt. Durch ein neues. Er hat es irgendwie per Twitter als mobile bezeichnet.
Also jetzt ist es überhaupt erstmal ein Studio. Also vorher war das hier nur ein Mischpult. Ganz früher hab ich ja versucht, alles digital zu machen. Das war eine totale Katastrophe. Das hat zwar immer irgendwie funktioniert, aber das Ausmaß an Sachen, die da schief gehen können und dann auch schief gehen, ist so enorm. Und es ist so kompliziert, mit Software das Ganze zu machen, zuverlässig zu machen. Und vor allem ist es einfach extrem schwierig, solche Effekte, wie hier zum Beispiel mit dem Kompressor, den ich jetzt hier drin habe, in Software nachzubilden. Und dann eben auch noch ein Echtzeit-Signal im Kopfhörer zu haben. Das ist das eigentliche Problem, Latenz. Und deswegen mache ich ja schon länger jetzt einfach in Ermangelung von anderen soliden Lösungen. Also ich könnte es anders machen, aber ich hatte einfach keine, die solide waren. Deswegen habe ich einen normalen Mixer genommen. Deswegen nehme ich auch nur die Summe auf, was ja auch erstmal ausreicht, wenn das ordentlich aufgenommen ist. Jetzt habe ich das Ganze aufgebrochen in verschiedene Komponenten, in 19 Zoll Komponenten. Das ist halt einfach ein Vorverstärker, ein Kompressor, ein Expander, ein Mixer und halt der Kopfhörerverstärker, weil wir hier halt immer alles mit Kopfhörern aufnehmen, was jetzt auch nicht unbedingt immer sein muss. Man kann auch mit deutlich weniger Aufwand das machen, aber das ist halt jetzt mal ein Studio und das ist halt in so einem transportablen Rack und so kann ich das einfach an einem Griff hier nehmen und wegschmeißen.
Also ein 9 Zoll Rack mit, was sind das jetzt? Vier Höheneinheiten?
19 Zoll.
Ne, in 19 Zoll meinte ich ja und vier Höheneinheiten?
Das sind vier Höheneinheiten, genau. Und ich bräuchte jetzt noch eine fünfte Höheneinheit, die ich halt jetzt nicht habe.
Aber keine volle Tiefe, muss man auch dazu sagen.
Nein, nein, das ist alles relativ schmal hier. Das entspricht auch noch, ich hab eben gerade mal nachgeschaut, noch den IATA Handgepäckgrößen. Also ein Handgepäckstück laut IATA-Empfehlung sei alles, was Höhe plus Breite plus Länge oder Tiefe sind, unter 115 cm ist Handgepäck.
Also du kannst das beim Flugzeug im Handgepäck mitnehmen?
Theoretisch, praktisch.
Mit 15 Kilo?
Ach, ich meine, der eine wiegt 96 Kilo, der andere wiegt 50, die paar Kilo mehr oder weniger bringen. Aber du wiegst doch. Man wird noch nicht gewogen. So weit sind wir noch nicht. Vielleicht kommt das nach den Nackts, wie auch immer. Ich habe ja keine Ahnung. Ich will damit jetzt auch nicht durch die Gegend fliegen, sondern es geht ja einfach darum, dass man eben das, so wie es ist, ohne eine Myriade an Kabeln und Adaptern und Geräten, die man alle einzeln einpacken muss und verstauen muss und sichern muss, dass sie auch transportgerecht verpackt sind, dass man einfach hier Deckel drauf macht, Griff und ab ins Auto oder welches Transportmittel auch immer und dann packt man das irgendwo, wo man angekommen ist, aus, stellt es auf den Tisch, Strom ran und die Scheiße ist fertig. Darum ging es. Und ich wollte unbedingt mal einen Kompressor haben und das ist jetzt die erste Sendung, die ich mit einem Live-Kompressor aufnehme. Und das sollte jetzt zum Beispiel schon mal den Effekt haben, dass ich nicht so sehr viel lauter klinge als ihr. Ich weiß nicht, ob das jetzt auch wirklich so ankommt. Soweit ich das hier höre, aber ich bin auch nicht der Maßstab, schon.
Ich frag ja gerade quasi in den Chat hinein.
Ach du fragst ja in den Chat hinein.
Klingt sehr gut. Doch passt.
Also wir sind halt sozusagen alle komprimiert mit unterschiedlichen Settings. Ich bin nicht komprimiert. Du bist auch komprimiert. 4 zu 1 bist du komprimiert, mein Freund. Echt?
Deswegen bin ich so dumpf. Oder wie?
Ich bin so stark komprimiert.
Ich fühl mich selbst dumpf.
Ich kann dich mal ein bisschen rausnehmen von der Komprimierung.
Hallo, hallo, hallo.
Bist du jetzt weniger dumpf?
Dumpf? Dumpf? Weiß ich nicht.
Mach ich mal wieder ein bisschen dumpfer.
Findet irgendjemand, dass Dennis dumpf ist? Loll heißt es da. Tja, ist auf jeden Fall ein schönes Ding. Was ich jetzt hier noch machen könnte, ist, wenn ich jetzt ein fünftes, also angenommen, ich würde jetzt sagen, ok, cool, Rack ist ja einfach die Lösung. Wo ich jetzt derzeit der Meinung bin, aber ich hab schon häufig geglaubt, dass ich jetzt die perfekte Lösung zu haben. Genau. Und am Ende des Weges angekommen bin.
Ein Low Cut.
Bitte?
Ein Low Cut. Ein Low Cut auf Tim wäre nicht schockiert.
Filter?
Du bist auf Low Cut, seit wann das denn?
Achso, ein Low Cut. Tja, ein Low Cut. Ich seh mir das System hier noch nicht, muss ich sagen.
Es gibt auch so Low-Cut-iPhone-Programme.
Ich hab zu viel Bass, Alter.
Ich seh das nur ab und zu bei anderen Leuten.
Kann ich denn hier überhaupt? Auf dem Mixer hab ich keine Höhen- und Tiefenänderung.
Tims sucht immer noch den Low Cut.
Den Low Cut hab ich hier nicht. Der ist abgeschnitten.
Und gleich wieder ein neues Gerät kaufen.
Ach. Es geht hier auf jeden Fall immer noch mehr. Aber dann braucht man auch mehr Höhen-Einheiten, dann wird es halt irgendwie unportabel.
Ich wollt grad sagen, da ist kein Platz mehr frei. Da sind nicht so acht Etagen, wo man noch was nachschieben kann, bei dem was du hier hast. Das hat mich doch ein bisschen verwundert.
Na gut, aber ich kann einfach ein anderes Rack kaufen. Ich kann mir dann vor allem, also der nächste Schritt wäre, dass man sich ein Rack bauen lässt, was sozusagen genau in den eigenen Ansprüchen genügt. Weil das hat ja auch was mit optionalen Ein- und Ausgängen, die hinten liegen, Strom und so weiter zu tun. Da muss ich noch mal gucken. Erstmal so.
Okay, mit anderen Worten, es besteht noch Erweiterungspotenzial.
Genau. Ich soll weniger rumpeln, heißt es hier.
Ich glaube, das kann sein, dass mit dem Rumpeln...
Das liegt an meiner Sonorenstimme.
Das Rumpeln? Nee, ich glaube, das mit dem Rumpeln, das ist... Hört man das? Kann sein, dass ich das bin.
Tja, und AAC. Warum haben wir denn keinen AAC, Max?
Was?
Warum gibt es denn unseren Podcast nur einen MP3?
Ich scheue mich so ein bisschen... Seniorenstimme. Ich scheue mich so ein bisschen davor. Tim hat ein fantastisches neues WordPress-Plugin rausgesucht. Also wir machen das im Augenblick noch mit dem ganz, ganz furchtbaren Podpress, was unter anderem die Umlaute nicht richtig kann, wie er bei jedem Podcast sich irgendjemand zu Recht drüber beschwert. Und dann hast du irgendwann mal dieses neue Podcasting-Plugin. Wie heißt das?
Das heißt Podcasting.
Das heißt Podcasting. Man sucht nach WordPress und Podcasting, dann findet man das auch. Und das sieht auf den ersten Blick, da hab ich erstmal eine Testinstallation gemacht auf einem anderen Blog und das sieht erstmal alles so weit ganz großartig aus. Und jetzt scheue ich mich noch ein ganz klein wenig davor, das so hopp-ladi-hopp zu installieren, weil dieser iTunes-RSS-Feed ist mir immer ein bisschen so spektronisch. Ich hab ein bisschen Angst davor, dass wir vielleicht aus dem iTunes-Store dann rausfliegen könnten oder sowas, wenn ich dabei einen Fehler mache. Weswegen ich diesen Prozess gerne vorher drei- bis viermal trocken testen würde und ihn dann erst tatsächlich durchhören. Das mach ich aber bald.
Genau, mach das mal, das wäre ganz gut.
Und dann gibt's AAC und dann gibt's Umlaute im Feed und dann gibt's alles für euch. Und Kekse für den App.
Was ich noch erwähne, weil wir gerade hier bei AAC und iTunes sind, es war letztens auf Slashdot, weil man soll ja immer seine Quellen erwähnen und so, war eine Ankündigung, dass die wieder so einen MP3-Vergleichstest machen. Und zwar bei Hydrogen Audio.
Darf ich mal ganz kurz, du hast gerade rumgespielt, weil ich übersteuere wohl gerade, kam im Chat und Dennis übersteuert definitiv, wenn er redet.
Was?
Ganz massiv.
So ein Quatsch. Wo denn? Sieht man ja gar nichts von.
Wo denn?
Ganz zeit ein Gelb-Rot.
Du, übersteuern ist, wenn hier übersteuert wird. Das ist der Vorteil in so einem analogen Equipment. Das kann auch mal ein bisschen übersteuern. Das hat auf jeden Fall Luft nach oben.
Gut, egal. Kekse.
Gut, jedenfalls machen die wieder so einen MP3-Vergleichstest. Und dann haben die müssen ja dann immer irgendwie mit vergleichenden Lame-Encoder und den iTunes-Encoder und noch irgendwie einen anderen. Und damit die Hörer da unvoreingenommen testen können, entkoden sie halt nach einem MP3 mit den entsprechenden Programmen, machen danach wieder lossless, damit die Files alle gleich aussehen und man nicht reingucken kann. Und dann müssen die Hörer da testen. Und dabei haben die wohl festgestellt, dass es iTunes auf Dual-Prozessoren immer unterhalb der angegebenen Bitrate liegen würde. Haben dann auch schon mit den Apple-Entwicklern gesprochen, die hätten das Problem gleich zugegeben, waren da sehr entgegenkommt und haben das wohl auf ihrer Seite dort im Apple-Repository wie auch immer gleich gefixt. Und eventuell kommt da dann auch der nächste Update. Ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob die Musik kaputt ist oder ob sie nur einfach ein bisschen spätiger, ein bisschen weniger VR benutzen, als man angegeben hat. Aber da ist auf jeden Fall irgendwas nicht okay.
Kaputt wäre im Laufe der Zeit schon mal aufgefallen, oder?
Naja, weiß man nicht.
Weiß man nicht. Also hier, erinnerst du dich, wir haben uns im letzten Podcast über diese Improv Everywhere unterhalten. Die mit dem Freeze im Bahnhof und so. Und die waren ja jetzt in Berlin letztes Wochenende. Ich konnte dann leider ausgerechnet nicht. Warst du da?
Nee, ich war bei einem Umzug helfen.
Ja, ich auch. Und die Wahl am Alexanderplatz, ich weiß nicht, ob es geklappt hat. Ich hab dann noch mal zum Spaß irgendwie zeitgleich auch dieses MP3 dann gestartet. Auf meinem iPhone, nur um festzustellen, dass es nach zweieinhalb Minuten abbrach.
Wieso das denn?
Weiß ich nicht, aber ich vermute, es ist irgendwie scheiße encoded gewesen. Oder es gab ein Bug im iPhone, dass ein richtig encodedes MP3 nicht richtig abspielt. Aber ich habe es dann drei-, viermal auseinander ausprobiert und es ist immer bei 239, hat es sich beendet.
Vielleicht versehentlich runtergeladen? Das würde ich eher vermuten jetzt. Weil dieses MP3-Hand, das er auch nicht das erste Mal benutzt, das war ja schon das gleiche MP3-Hand.
Na, es hat mir zumindest gesagt, dass es 45 Minuten lang sei.
Laufzeit 2.30 sind wir jetzt gerade.
Ich hab Pumpe.
Wie 2.30?
Ich glaube, wir sind bei 2.30.
Echt?
Mein MP3 ging, meint jemand, Funkmonk.
Stimmt.
Wie viele Seiten denn am Chat?
2,5 Stunden, das ist echt zu viel. Wie viele Seiten denn im Chat? Was ist denn da los?
40, 40 ist doch nicht viel.
Hallo, meine Herren, ganz schön was los hier.
Dann ist das jetzt auch mal der richtige Zeitpunkt.
War ganz nett, aber nicht so der Überhammer. Gab's denn überhaupt Videos davon? Ich hab noch nichts gesehen.
Das soll wohl alles sehr gut dokumentiert werden, oder da wird es noch Videos geben, die sitzen wahrscheinlich noch in ihren Schnittstudios und warten drauf, bis wir es haben.
MP3 ist auf jeden Fall ein Problem. Also es gibt da immer wieder so Sachen. Was auch ein Problem ist, ist diese Sachen mit den Kapiteln. Haben wir uns darüber schon mal unterhalten?
Sachen und Kapiteln?
Mit MP3 und Kapiteln.
Es gibt auch so ein, nee so richtig noch nicht, aber es gibt so ein Standard dafür, glaube ich, wo man das in ID3-Tags unterbringen kann. Den kann aber so ziemlich niemand vermute ich mal.
Genau. Also ich kenne ein einziges Tool, was in der Lage ist, Kapitelinformationen in MP3s auszuwerten.
Auszuwerten und in welcher Form?
In der Form, dass es weiß, wo die sind und dass man diese Kapitel direkt anspringen kann.
Und das läuft nur auf einem Amiga 500, der irgendwo im Himalaya herumsteht?
Es ist noch absurder. Es handelt sich dabei um den Quicktime-Player.
Das haut mich jetzt aber wirklich um.
Ja, mich auch. And here is the story. Also es gibt diesen Standard, den gibt es jetzt seit drei Jahren. Nobody cares a fucking shit about it. Ich verstehe nicht, warum. Es gibt viele Apologeten, die der Meinung sind, man sollte ja MPEG 4 unbedingt mal vermeiden, weil das wäre irgendwie evil und böse und macht Kratzer und Ausschlag und Aids und was nicht alles. Da kann man jetzt beidem eine Meinung drüber sein. Und die schreien dann alle nach MP3. Aber alle schreien auch nach Kapiteln. Aber keiner kümmert sich darum, mal diesen Standard der Kapitel für MP3 auch mal zu implementieren oder beziehungsweise überhaupt erstmal ein Tool zu schreiben, mit dem man diese Dinger erzeugen kann. Das schadet ja nichts, wenn da so ein ID3-Tech drin ist. MP3 kannst du dann trotzdem noch abspielen. Ich hab dann irgendwann mal geforscht. Und ich hab dann so verschiedene Tools ausprobiert, die so generell diese Kapitelgeschichte machen auf dem Mac. Normalerweise, um das eben in diese MP4-AC-Dateien einzubauen. Und dann gab's eins, jetzt hab ich den Namen schon wieder vergessen. Damit hab ich so ein MP3 aufgemacht. Ich hab so ein paar Kapitelinformationen eingegeben. Und dann bin ich irgendwie so auf Apfel S gekommen. Hab mich so gewundert, dass es irgendwie eine Funktion hatte. Und dann hab ich mich gewundert, was er denn jetzt getan hat. Und dann hab ich festgestellt, oh, er hat jetzt das in das MP3 abgespeichert. Und stellte dann fest...
Welches Programm war das?
Das hatte ich dann vergessen. Eins von denen. Ich komm gleich noch drauf. Und diese Datei hab ich dann halt in QuickTime Player geöffnet. Und zu meinem größten Verdutz tauchten halt diese Kapitel auf. Also erstens war ich verdutzt, dass ich ein Tool gefunden hatte, was tatsächlich in der Lage war, das da reinzuschreiben. Obwohl ich ja eben noch behauptet habe, es gibt keins. Und dass es auch noch eins gab, was es anzeigen konnte, dass es sich dabei auch noch um den QuickTime Player handelt, hat mich komplett vom Stuhl geworfen. Ich weiß nicht mehr ganz genau, ich bin dann irgendwie abgelenkt worden, hab das dann irgendwie ein paar Tage vertagt und dann bin ich nicht mehr dazu gekommen. Und neulich hab ich dann nochmal geschaut, ob ich dieses Tool nochmal finde, weil ich hat es definitiv nicht mehr auf meiner Platte. Und das Tool, von dem ich jetzt glaube, was es war, wo ich jetzt aber wieder den Namen vergessen habe, steht nicht mehr zum Download bereit. Es gibt dieses Tool nicht mehr für den Mac. Und mir ist auch sonst nichts über den Weg genommen. Das einzige Stück Software, was behauptet, dass es das kann, ist ein von der BBC geschriebenes Stück Java, das ID3 Chapter Tool heißt und nicht auf dem Mac läuft, weil es nach irgendeinem bekloppten Java-Library fragt, die, keine Ahnung, Bodennebe, irgendwas, irgendeinen Kack, läuft auf jeden Fall nicht. Lange Rede, kurzer Sinn. Es gibt hier diesen Standard. Er würde total Sinn machen, das einfach einzubauen. Und jedes MP3, damit man diese Kapitelinformation schon mal hat, dann kann man darauf warten, dass die Tools kommen, die es unterstützen. Ich weiß bis heute noch nicht, ob der iPod oder das iPhone, und beim iPhone bin ich relativ hoffnungsfroh, weil ja der QuickTime-Player das auch kann und das ist ja nun mal irgendwie das QuickTime. Dass auch dort MP3-Chapters ausgewertet werden könnten, wenn sie es denn mal gäbe.
Hast du das MP3 noch, mit dem du es ausprobiert hast?
Nein.
Ah, schade. Ansonsten wäre es einfach gewesen.
Ja, das ist das Problem. Ich habe kein MP3, mit dem ich es testen könnte. Ich habe dieses Tool nicht mehr gefunden, mit dem man es machen kann. Dieses Java-Tool, was behauptet, es könnte es, läuft nicht auf dem Mac. Hast du keinen Parallels? Doch, ich habe einen VM-Ware. Und dann?
Benutz das da.
Du willst mich jetzt wegen Windows zu benutzen?
Nein, keinen Fall, mach ich auch nicht.
Ja eben.
Nicht mal virtuell, geht gar nicht.
Das sollen andere Leute machen, ich mach sowas nicht. Auf jeden Fall, Hilfe ist geboten. Also ich würde mich sehr freuen, wenn mal so ein bisschen die Podcast-Gemeinde sich vielleicht dieses Thema auch nochmal annimmt. Vielleicht gibt es ja ein paar coole Lösungen. Also so schwierig kann es auch nicht sein, ein paar ID.3-Tags reinzumachen.
Naja, das Problem ist dann, die wieder rauszuholen. Also ich meine, wenn das iPhone ist, kann das ja schön und gut.
Die rausholen.
Ich meine, welche Programme können die denn anzeigen?
Ist doch egal, erst mal rein damit, stört doch nicht.
Ja okay, aber wenn es niemand nutzen kann, dann ist das ja auch albern. Bei ARC weiß man wenigstens, okay, das können die iPads nutzen, das können die iPhone nutzen.
Ja, aber wenn ich eine Tool-Chain habe, also angenommen, wir würden jetzt für Mobamex Kapitel machen. Angenommen, ich hätte jetzt hier so einen Fußtaster die ganze Zeit und ich würde jedes Mal, wenn wir das Thema wechseln, einfach machen. Und dann hätte ich eine Software laufen, die sich einfach den Timecode merkt. Wo ich einem einfach mal startgesagt habe, dass es synchron mit der Aufnahme, vielleicht auch dasselbe Tool, und dann merkt er sich einfach diese Kapitel-Information. Und danach ist die Datei fertig, liegt als AEFF vor und dann sage ich, okay, jetzt machen wir mal meine Podcast-Files. Und zwar hätte ich gerne MP3, 96 Kilobit, VBR, lalala.
Und schmeißt das als Kapitelmarken rein.
Und schmeißt doch das mal als Kapitelmarken rein. Und machen wir das dann Ganze auch nochmal als MP4 auch noch mit Kapitelmarken.
Das wär gut.
Das wär gut. Wie gut wär das? Und dann könnte man zu diesen ganzen Open Source-Jüngern latschen und sagen, hier, ihr habt doch so einen coolen Player und ihr findet doch alle ARC-Scheiße. Interpretiert doch mal bitte dieses ID3-Tag. Ihr interpretiert doch die anderen ID3-Tags auch. Und da steht der Titel drin, da steht das Album drin, hier steht die Kapitelinformation drin. Kann man nicht so schwer sein. Und dann baut man das halt einfach ein und dann gibt's das. Und dann hat man auch dieses Henne-Eye-Problem irgendwie elegant gelöst und dann kann man immer noch, dann kann man endlich mal behaupten, dass irgendein anderer MP3-Player vielleicht irgendwas besser macht als ein iPod.
Hast du dir mal dieses MP3-Rage-Tool angeguckt? Dieses Über-Tag-Tool? Selbst wenn die das nicht haben, sind das genau die richtigen Jungs, denen man mal sagt, dass man so ein Feature haben will. Das müssten die relativ schnell hinkriegen, weil die haben sowieso alles modularisiert.
Tja, müssten die eigentlich hinkriegen. Ich meine, bisher machen die nur so Global-Informationen am Arm, nicht wirklich so ein Kapitel-Interface. Das wär mir neu. Es gibt verschiedene...
Die haben so modulmäßig alles so organisiert, wo man auch irgendwie seine Module skripten kann inzwischen.
I don't know. Keine Ahnung. Also hier ist halt ein bisschen User-Interface-Interaktion oder irgendwie Datei-Interpretation nötig. Ein richtig gutes Tool gibt es sowieso nicht. Es gibt auch für Subtitle-Sätzen kein richtig gutes Tool. Es gibt nur so Crapware. Also alles so Software, die versucht ganz schick zu sein, aber eigentlich kein wirklich stringentes Interface hat. Mir ist zumindest noch nichts untergekommen, was mich wirklich überzeugt.
Ja, ich hab ja gestern mal wieder ein Movie gerippt. Ich mach ja sowas mal gelegentlich. Na eigentlich mach ich sowas nicht mehr, weil ich...
Aber nur deine Heimvideos.
Ja, von Blu-ray, damit du das auf dem MacBook abspielen kannst.
Nee, war eine normale DVD. Jedenfalls wollte ich die Untertitel auch haben. Und dieses scheiß Handbrake hat mir die Untertitel ins Bild reingerendert. Was ist denn das für ein Kack? Dafür kann man noch in QuickTime eine eigene Videospur machen, die man sich dann zusätzlich ein- und ausschaltet, oder? Was sind das für Pfeifen?
Und der iPhone unterstützt das angeblich auch.
Ja, also ist mir auch erstmal egal.
Google macht das auch.
Aber ich meine, das QuickTime kann das alles, dass man dann noch eine zweite Videospur macht, die man dann als Overlay irgendwie drüberlegt, wo prima irgendwie die Subtitles reinkönnen, wenn nicht sowieso QuickTime Subtitles als Text direkt kann. Das wäre noch sparsamer, weiß ich gar nicht. Aber jedenfalls muss man das nicht ins Bild reinrennen, dass das denn... Wie schlecht ist das denn? Ja, den muss man echt mal schreiben, das geht ja gar nicht. Aber immerhin können Sie mehrere Audio spuren und dann kann man auch in QuickTime sich die...
Und die neue Version von Handbrake kann jetzt auch Videos encoden, die nicht als DVD vorliegen, in der neuesten Version.
Oh mein Gott.
Man kann jetzt auch so Avids nehmen und...
Und unkohne, yeah, Endledge.
Ja, das war in der Tat ein Schritt nach vorne. Hab ich noch nicht so viel benutzt, aber... Hab ich schon mal ausprobiert, funktioniert grundsätzlich so. Ah, jetzt sind wir aber langsam am Ende hier, oder?
Ich bin total am Ende.
Ja, wir entlassen euch mal. Tja, das war's, oder? Supermax Nummer 17, noch ohne Titel, aber wir finden gleich einen. Und ich hoffe, ja, Kommentare wie immer erbeten bei uns im Blog. Schreibt mal ein bisschen was dazu. Wie ihr das hier so von der Audioqualität gefunden habt, das würde mich sehr interessieren. Da ist jetzt hier sicherlich das letzte Wort noch nicht gesprochen. Da müssen noch ein paar Settings getunt werden und so. Ansonsten Fragen, Vorschläge, Kritik, immer erwünscht. Und auch möchten wir euch geradezu dazu ermuntern. Was haben wir noch? Gibt es noch was?
Sonst gibt es nichts.
Das Cocoa-Hats-Treffen ist morgen.
Ist es denn jetzt doch morgen?
Da waren zwar unterschiedliche Aussagen, aber der Typi, der das ja wohl auch frisch gerade losstartet, hat irgendwie noch mal irgendwo explizit geschrieben, dass es am dreizehnten Morgen ist. Und ich war ja letzte Woche auch da und die hat auf ihren Plan gehuckt und meinte, ne, für den dreizehnten um 19 Uhr hätte sie einen Termin.
Ja, jetzt hab ich mir einen anderen Termin gewählt.
Welchen denn?
Na jetzt muss ich hier zu Hause bleiben.
Achso. Ja, ich werd da morgen mal hin schauen, mal gucken.
Vielleicht wenn es früh oder so. Entlassen wir alle, wa?
Genau, bis zum nächsten Mal.
Okay, bis bald.